bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat pour suivre dans un
instant une audition qui s'est tenue la
semaine dernière au Sénat celle de
Jean-Bernard Lévi Jean-Bernard Lévy est
le PDG de DF il a été auditionné par les
sénateurs de la commission des affaires
économiques qui a pour président le
sénateur les républiqu Jean-Claude
Lenoir pendant près de 2hes Jean-Bernard
Levi s'est exprimé notamment sur la
situation financière compliquée du géant
français de l'électricité dont la dette
atteint plus de 37 milliards d'euros je
le rappelle il y a 15 jours d'ailleurs
l'état principal actionnaire actionnaire
à 85 % du groupe a d'ailleurs réinjecté
dans les caisses 3 milliards d'euros une
situation qui met en difficulté des
investissement prévu notamment et bien
la mise en sûreté des centrales
existantes mais aussi des projets
d'avenir comme les PR pr de flamandville
de taan mais surtout d'incle point incle
point et bien c'est un projet
aujourd'hui controversé qui doit émerger
en Grande-Bretagne un projet pour lequel
milite très activement vous allez le
voir Jean-Bernard levville tout de suite
donc retour à cette audition qui s'est
tenue la semaine dernière au
Sénat nous allons vous entendre monsieur
le Président détailler ces mesures mais
comporte notamment le soutien de l'État
à travers une augmentation de capital et
par le versement de son dividende en
action pour les deux prochaines années
en même temps baisse des investissements
économie supplémentaire efforts qui
seront fait session d'actifs et cetera
bon il reste que certains projets de DF
sont aujourd'hui contestés nous allons
en reparler notamment concernant incle
point mais d'ors et déjà et avant de
vous entendre monsieur le Président euh
vous posez quelques questions qui vont
vous éclairer
sur la demande de de la
Commission concernant incle point est-il
exact qu'il y a des
garanties sur le prix mais pas sur le
volume c'estàdire est-ce
que le consommateur britannique s'engage
à consommer un certain volume
d'électricité garanti qu'idé pour ce qui
est du prix quel est d'autre part son
partage des risques entre EDF et son
partenaire chinois
CGN avec lequel
EDF a construit plusieurs réacteurs en
Chine la question aussi de la
disponibilité
euh de ces réacteurs et de la durée de
réalisation de
l'investissement est-ce que les
durées annoncé seront seront
respecté vous allez d'autre part bien
sûr nous parler d'aré je veux pas
prolonger trop puisque j'ai déjà dit à
mes collègues qui auront 2 minutes je le
redis ici pour poser une question il me
reste 10 secondes
pour vous dire qu'il y aura également
des questions sur
faenheim sur la réduction de la part du
nucléaire qui est prévu par la loi de
transition
énergétique annoncé pour une part dans
le cadre de la PPE mais incomplète
puisque la part du nucléaire de la PPE
n'est pas connu il y a aussi quantité
d'autres questions qui sont relayées par
l'équipe que vous avez devant vous qui
est la commission des affaires
économiques monsieur le Président je
vous donne la parole merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs je suis j'ai
grand plaisir à venir m'entretenir avec
vous vous parler quelques minutes euh
deedf et puis bien sûr surtout répondre
à à vos questions dans dans quelques
instants la la situation deedf suscite
beaucoup de questions et euh je dirais
le le le sujet majeur et c'est pour ça
que nous nous sommes permis de vous
distribuer une planche un graphique le
problème majeur c'est que nous devons
aujourd'hui sur notre principal marché
celui de la vente de la production
d'électricité ce qu'on appelle le marché
de gros nous nous avons aujourd'hui un
marché comme vous l'avez sur les le
cument distribué un marché très déprimé
où les prix ont été divisés par de en 2
ans ils sont aujourd'hui autour de 27 à
28 € contre plus de 50 € en 2014 et même
60 €
précédemment les raisons son
principalement la baisse du prix des
matières premières énergétiques comme le
charbon et et le gaz le pétrole derrière
et puis aussi le fait que la croissance
n'est pas revenu alors que de nouvelles
capacités de production vous l'avez dit
monsieur le président se déploie de
façon soutenue en France et dans les
pays
limitrophes nous ne sommes pas les seuls
à connaître une situation difficile et
et je dirais même que la plupart des
énergéticiens en France et dans les pays
voisins ont rencontré des difficultés
plutôt plus fortes que les nôtres ils
ont tous eu des résultats déficitaires
certains d'entre eux sont en train de se
cinder en en deux ou plusieurs
entreprises indépendantes il n'est
question ni de l'un ni de l'autre pour
EDF nous sommes un groupe intégré et qui
a vocation à le rester et nous sommes
restés là aussi chaque année
bénéficiaire nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui eu le moindre exercice
déficitaire et je voudrais souligner que
c'est euh un hommage rendu à la
compétence à la mobilisation des des
salariés et aussi au choix historique
qu'a fait la France en faveur du
nucléaire qui comme vous le savez
représente aujourd'hui 75 % de la
production et qui nous permet de mettre
à la disposition de nos clients une
énergie et surtout une électricité bien
moins chère que chez tous nos voisins
une électricité abondante qui assure la
sécurité d'approvisionnement de la
France qui nous permet d'exporter donc
de maintenir ou de créer des emplois en
France et puis bien sûr une électricité
qui est particulièrement décarbonée à
mon
arrivée j'ai estimé nécessaire de donner
un cadre de travail à long terme pour
EDF cela s'appelle notre stratégie cap
2030 une stratégie qui s'inscrit dans la
transition énergétique et qui est fondée
sur nos nos convictions de ce que sera
le monde de demain demain l'énergie sera
bas carbone il y a des facteurs
climatiques des facteurs géopolitiques
qui fait que il y a une forte demande
une forte euh demande de l'opinion
publique à ce que euh l'énergie
contribue euh à euh limiter les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre demain
les consommateurs seront aussi des
acteurs en matière énergétique
historiquement le consommateur était
passif demain il va s'occuper lui-même
de piloter sa consommation grâce à des
outils numériques il sera lui-même un
producteur il pourra vendre
l'électricité bah à lui-même mais aussi
à ses voisins demain nous verrons que de
nombreux moteurs de la croissance
économique fonctionne à l'électricité
j'en citerai deux la mobilité électrique
que ça soit les transports collectifs ou
les véhicules individuels et puis le
développement rapide des technologie de
l'information et de la communication
qu'on pense data center ou que l'on
pense à tous les objets du quotidien que
nous avons aujourd'hui dans nos
domiciles et qui March à l'électricité
et quelquefois nous laissons tous les
uns les autres n'est-ce pas nos
chargeurs toute la journée à chauffer on
pourrait d'ailleurs faire attention
moi le premier bien sûr et donc dans ce
modèle où la la production décentralisée
va se superposer au modèle centralisé et
hiérarchique actuel EDF qui est
évidemment l'archétype du modèle
centralisé et hiérarchique doit apporter
des réponses et c'est l'objet de notre
stratégie cap 2030 notre premier
objectif c'est de développer des offres
compétitives numérique et décentralisé
que nos clients attendent que ça soit
nos clients ménagent que ça soit les
territoires les collectivités locales
qui cherchent eux-mêmes à déterminer
leur propre transition énergétique le
deuxième objectif c'est en matière de
production nous avons un mix bas carbone
particulièrement remarquable nous jouons
très bien de la complémentarité entre
les énergies nouvelles renouvelables
l'hydraulique autrre énergie renouvela
mais plus ancienne et bien sûr le le
nucléaire et puis nous voulons
bénéficier de complément de croissance
pour le groupe EDF dans des zones
géographiques dynami nous pourrons
apporter notre expertise d'électricien
bac
carbone nous avons une caractéristique
qui est très forte en matière
d'innovation chez EDF nous sommes l'un
des rares électriciens sinon le seul à
avoir historiquement de forte capacité
d'innovation autonome puisque nous
dépensons chaque année environ 600
millions d'euros à travers des équipes
fortes de 2000 chercheurs en matière de
recherche et développement
ces chercheurs sont principalement
localisé en en France mais ils le sont
aussi dans d'autres pays du monde et
j'étais récemment en Californie nous
avons une petite équipe qui est au cœur
de la silicone valally pour justement
être au courant de toutes ces
interactions entre énergie et numérique
qui sont très importantes pour le le
monde de demain nous voulons nous
inscrire dans des écosystèmes travailler
avec les les start-ups les incubateurs
et bien sûr les acteurs du monde
scientifique et
académique et ça se traduit déjà
concrètement puisque 10 millions de nos
clients 10 millions de nos clients ont
déjà un espace client digital et notre
application qui aide nos clients à faire
des économies d'énergie qui s'appelle
équilibre est déjà en usage dans 1
million de foyers à travers notamment
les
smartphones nous voulons aussi
développer des solutions décentralisées
pour répondre à la demande des
collectivités territoriales et souvent
on le sait les solutions innovantes
passent par les territoires je suis
frappé lors de mes déplacements dans les
grandes métropoles provinciales de voir
l'effervescence d'innovation qu'il y a
et le rôle que nous jouons localement
pour faire faciliter la mise en place de
solutions adéquate de solutions sur
mesure pour ces différents territoires
nous voulons donc identifier valoriser
les potentiels d'énergie renouvelable
local comme par exemple la chaleur
renouvelable la biomasse ou la
géothermie pour alimenter des réseaux de
chaleur ou de froid nous sommes au
premier plan en matière de solution de
mobilité électrique nous innovons dans
l'éclairage public et bien sûr et et
Madame la Ministre seolen royale il fait
référence fréquemment nous avons à
innover et nous le faisons en matière
d'efficacité énergétique des
bâtiments je donnerai quelques exemples
l'ensemble éolien catalan 96 MW qui
permettra dès cet été de valoriser le
potentiel de vent des Pyrénées
Orientales produisant l'équivalent de la
consommation d'une ville de 120000
habitants l'une des plus grandes fermes
éoliennes de France deuxème exemple en
vender nous travaillons avec le syndicat
départemental d'énergie de manière à
déployer 125 bornes de recharge
électrique pour mailler le territoire du
département cette infrastructure son
exploitation et sa gestion en sont
assuré par notre filiale
séelle le deuxè axe de notre stratégie
c'est la la production bas carbone je ne
rappellerai pas le le succès de la de la
COP 21 mais je voudrais dire que EDF de
ce point de vue-là est d'ors et déjà
exemplaire puisque nous disposons d'un
parc de production qui n'émet que 15 g
de CO2 par kWh produit et que c'est un
chiffre exceptionnel c'est 20 fois moins
que la moyenne des pays européens 15 G
20 fois moins que 310 g les les voisins
européens cela est grâce au choix
historiques remarquables qui ont été
fait dans notre pays des choix
historiques qui font que notre parc de
production repose essentiellement sur
des énergies renouvelables et sur du
nucléaire vous le savez nous avons des
ambitions forte en matière de
développement des énergies renouvelables
d'abord nous avons encore à exploiter
davantage notre potentiel hydraulique et
puis nous avons aussi à faire reposer
nos efforts sur l'éolien le soleil et la
chaleur renouvelable on l'ignore souvent
mais EDF est le premier producteur
d'énergie renouvelable en Europe est
l'un des premiers dans le monde derrière
les opérateurs chinois chaque année nous
investissons 2 milliards d'euros un peu
plus de 2 milliards d'euros pour
produire de nouvelles capacités de
renouvelable soit un peu plus que notre
investissement dans les nouveaux moyens
de production d'électricité d'origine
nucléaire notre objectif à l'horizon
2030 c'est de doubler la capacité du
parc d'électricité renouvelable que nous
exploitons en le passant de 28 à 50
GW je voudrais souligner que notre
présence en matière d'énergie
renouvelable se se déploie en France
mais aussi dans d'autres pays nous avons
des contrats d'approvisionnement
importants avec des des grands noms
comme Ikea Google ou ou Microsoft et je
je vous donne volontiers un exemple un
parc éolien que nous avons euh lancé
mise en service près de Chicago 175 MW
103 éolienne qui vont alimenter des data
centers de Microsoft qui lui veut
vis-à-vis de ses clients pouvoir
afficher qu'il fournit ses clients avec
de l'énergie renouvelable moi je suis
convaincu que notre avenir repose sur le
bon mix entre le renouvelable et le
nucléaire le nucléaire apporte bien sûr
une excellente disponibilité une
excellente prévisibilité et un coût très
compétitif les renouvelables apportent
un complément décarboné très puissant
lorsqu'il vendent ou qu'il fait soil
et nous avons donc misise en œuvre des
méthodes de gestion de notre parc qui
sont assez uniques au monde et qui nous
permettent de moduler la production
nucléaire de manière à ce qu'elle
complète la production
renouvelable nous devons donc au-delà du
développement des énergies renouvelables
conforter aussi notre parc nucléaire
existant ça veut dire vous le savez
faire le grand carénage programme
indispensable un programme de grande
ampleur pour l'ensemble de la filière
nucléaire porteur d'emploi mais aussi un
programme très rentable pour notre
collec
nationale et dès mon arrivée à EDF j'ai
demandé au Conseil d'Administration
qu'il a voté que le principe de ce
programme soit conforté ça a été fait en
janvier 2015 nous allons donc prolonger
la durée de fonctionnement de nos
centrales tout en augmentant encore le
niveau de sûreté et tout ceci faisant se
faisant sous le contrôle et sous réserve
de l'accord de l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire le coût du grand carénage 51
milliards d'euros courant de 2014 à 2025
c'est 15 % de moins que notre évaluation
initiale nous avons pu optimiser les
coûts du du grand carénage et le grand
carénage va être dans les années qui
viennent le premier poste de dépenses
d'investissement pour EDF sur les 10
années c'est en moyenne 40 % de nos
investissements annuels que nous
consacrerons à ce
programme le grand carénage c'est donc
un bon investissement puisqu'il
permettra aux Français de continuer à
bénéficier de l'électricité au meilleur
coût puisqu'il s'agit pour l'essentiel
de conserver en améliorant la sûreté de
conserver des installations existantes
mais nous devons aussi préparer l'avenir
du nucléaire avec les les PR et notre
premier objectif qui est véritablement
essentiel on dit volontiers stratégique
c'est de mettre en service le Pr de
flamandville nous avons franchi il y a
un mois au mois de mars comme prévu le
premier jalon clé conformément au
calendrier que nous nous avions mise à
jour à l'été 2015 et qui prévoit un
démarrage du réacteur au 4e trimestre
2018 une nouvelle organisation
industrielle a été mise en place pour
garantir la maîtrise du chantier avec
nos partenaires de façon beaucoup plus
transparente beaucoup
plus partagé et je crois que cette
nouvelle organisation du chantier en
tout cas pour l'instant s'avère
nettement plus efficace et puis il y a
bien sûr le le dossier inlep sur lequel
vous m'avez posé une première série de
questions prochainement le conseil
d'administration aura à se prononcer sur
le lancement de cet investissement pour
la construction de deux pr en
Grande-Bretagne cette décision je crois
qu'elle aurait été déjà prise si le les
prix de marché étaient restés à à 50 €.
elle aurait déjà été soumise au vote du
conseil d'administration mais avec la
baisse brutale des prix de marché qui
est intervenu à la fin de l'année
2015 cette conjoncture m'a imposé de
commencer par sécuriser la trajectoire
financière du groupeedf ne pas se lancer
dans cet investissement qui est
important sans avoir sécurisé la
trajectoire financière de DF ceci est
fait vous y avez fait allusion à travers
les annonces le jour de notre conseil
d'administration vendredi 22 vendredi
dernier j'y reviendrai dans dans un
instant j'ai aussi décidé de consulter
le comité central d'entreprise le CCE
car les représentants du personnel les
élus du CCE m on fait la demande de
manière unanime mais c'est un projet qui
je crois conserve toutes ses qualités et
qui et qui devra se faire pour de
nombreuses raisons le premier c'est que
le ce projet est extrêmement rentable
nous avons le bénéfice de ce qui
s'appelle le contrat pour différence
avec le gouvernement
britannique ce contrat pour différence
sécurise un prix de vente pendant 35 ans
de 2025 à 2060 ce prix est indexé sur
l'inflation ceci nous permet d'afficher
un taux de rentabilité de
l'investissement d'environ 9 % par an 9
% par an sur les 70 ans qui viennent 10
ans de construction 60 ans
d'exploitation et 95 % de cette valeur
créée et réalisée pendant les 35 ans où
le prix est garanti ce contrat aide
d'État a été validé par la commission
européenne il est donc robuste il n'est
pas fixé par une loi qui pourrait être
modifiée unilatéralement par le
gouvernement britannique à un moment ou
à un autre
c'est un contrat bilatéral entre l'État
britannique et l'entreprise que nous
sommes notre filiale qui construira et
exploitera les deux réacteurs et puis
nous n'investissons pas seul nous
investissons vous l'avez cité aussi avec
nos partenaires chinois CGN nos
partenaires de 30 ans qui connaissent le
Pr puisqu'ils ont construit deux
actuellement à taan et qui ont décidé de
porter un/ers de l'investissement total
soit 8 milliards d'euros ce projet est
rentable il se se déroule dans un
excellent climat de confiance avec nos
partenaires chinois et britanniques ce
projet est aussi mû tous les accords
avec l'État britannique et avec notre
partenaire CGN sont prêts ils ont été
approuvés par la Commission européenne
les contrats avec les principaux
fournisseurs et prestataires sont
finalisés je rappelle que ce n'était pas
le cas au moment du lancement de Flam
enville les équipes ont été organisé
elles sont prêtes les dirigeants du
projet ont été désignés bien sûr inlep
intégrera le retour d'expérience de
flamandville I et de Tachan c'est déjà
le cas en matière d'ingénierie et de
conduite de chantier ce sera le cas en
ce qui concerne la mise en service
puisque nous prévoyons que le premier
béton de sûreté c'est-à-dire l'érection
du bâtiment le début de l'érection du
bâtiment nucléaire qui interviendra en
2019 ce premier béton de sûreté
interviendra après la mise en service de
taiishan 1 et de flamandville 3 ces deux
réacteurs d'inkle point seront donc le
5e et le 6e pr à être construit dans le
monde alors on parle beaucoup des
risques j'ai demandé vu l'ampleur du
projet avec ma mes références
industriell dans ce secteur et dans
d'autres secteurs j'ai demandé qu'une
revue de risque soit conduite fin 2015
elle a établi que les risques sont
connus et surmontables moyennant la mise
en œuvre d'une série de recommandations
et j'ai décider d'appliquer l'ensemble
de ces recommandations il y aura bien
sûr au fur et à mes mesure de la vie de
ce projet de 10 ans d'autres revues de
risque c'est une procédure habituelle
pour des projets de cette
ampleur je voudrais vous dire que le
report d'inkle point ne me semble pas
opportun certains évoquent la
possibilité de reporter le projet après
la mise en service de flamandville et de
Tachan et ce n'est à mes yeux ni
nécessaire ni faisable les risques sont
nombreux le report de plusieurs années
amènerait le gouvernement britannique à
se tourner vers des solutions
alternatives et il ne manque pas
aujourd'hui de constructeur de réacteurs
nucléaires qui s'engouffreraiit dans la
brèche ainsi créée le contrat pour
différence deviendrait Cadu il faudrait
renégocier avec le gouvernement
britannique et avec la Commission de
Bruxelles le report du projet mettrait
aussi en péril notre partenariat avec
CGN notre partenaire chinois enfin nous
devrions également renégocier les
contrats avec les principaux
fournisseurs qui représentent environ 70
% des coûts et lesp déjà engagé sur le
projet serait en grande partie perdu je
suis donc convaincu que incle point doit
se faire il doit se faire maintenant dès
que nous aurons eu l' vie du comité
central d'entreprise je voudrais
souligner que la construction de ces pr
ouvre des
perspectiv absolument majeure pour
l'ensemble de notre filière française
d'excellence dans le nucléaire on pense
qu'il y a environ 220000 emplois en
France qui sont concernés par le
nucléaire le projet nous permettra de
disposer d'une offre plus compétitive
pour le renouvellement du parc lorsque
la question se posera en France il nous
permettra aussi d'être crédible à
l'exportation comment être crédible pour
vendre des pr à l'exportation si nous ne
commandons pas à nous-mêmes nos propres
produit je voudrais revenir maintenant
sur le contexte
économique la courbe que je vous ai
distribué montre l'ampleur et la
rapidité de l'évolution des des prix de
marché de de l'électricité
les causes de cette baisse des prix sont
sont bien connues il y a des facteurs de
consommation qui augmentent la
consommation
d'électricité mais il y a aussi des
facteurs de diminution de la
consommation d'électricité le plus
important et nous n'en sommes satisfaits
c'est l'efficacité énergétique c'est le
fait que les consommateurs les
entreprises les administration ou ou ou
les ménages sont plus attentifs mais il
y a aussi des facteurs de baisse durable
de la consommation d'électricité dans un
phénomène qu'il faut déplorer c'est
celui de la
désindustrialisation de notre pays qui
crée une baisse de la demande
d'électricité lorsque les usines
fortement consommatrices s'arrêtent et
on sait que dans la durée nous avons
perdu malheureusement des emplois
industriels en particulier dans ce qu'on
appelle les industries
électrointensives ces facteurs de baisse
ne sont pas vraiment compensé en volume
par la hausse induite par la démographie
par la hausse induite par le
développement des nouveaux usages de
l'électricité je parlais des Data Center
ou des véhicules électriques ce qui fait
que la demande d'électricité est stable
depuis plusieurs année alors que l'offre
augmente chaque année euh et que par
exemple en France nous avons connecté la
France 2000 MW d'énergie nouvelle
renouvelable en 2015 ce phénomène
apparaît durable les marchés nous
donnent des indications sur euh euh les
prix dans 2 ou 3 ans et il semble que
ces prix ne sont pas destinés à remonter
fortement avant 2 ou 3 ans ceci crée
pour EDF une situation très différente
de ce qu'elle était précédemment
pourquoi et bien parce que DF est
beaucoup plus fortement exposé au prix
de marché qu'il ne l'était il y a
quelques
années il y a quelques années nous
avions moins de 20 % de
nos productions qui se vendaient sur le
marché principalement la production pour
les industriels aujourd'hui c'est 65 %
de notre production qui se vend sur le
marché puisque nous avons
progressivement ouvert ver plutôt fait
mis fin au prix au prix régulés en
particulier sur les entreprises de toute
nature ce qu'on appelit les tarif jaune
et vert et nous avons donc le plein
effet en 2016 et 2017 de cette baisse
des des prix des prix de marché avec 65
% plus plus de trois fois plus le
chiffre d'il y a 3 ans de notre
production qui se vend aujourd'hui sur
sur le marché et donc ceci crée les
conditions d'un déséquilibre durable sur
les comptes d'EDF
entre les capacités de financement et
les besoins d'investissement ce
déséquilibre durable il est par certains
côtés soluble mais à condition de
prendre des
mesures et c'est tout l'objet du plan
que j'ai présenté en conseil
d'administration vendredi dernier et que
je vais vous décrire maintenant ces
mesures sont indispensables car nous
n'avons pas le choix que d'investir il
n'est pas question que nous nous
arrêtions d'investir je l'ai dit nous
avons besoin de faire le grand carénage
et de conforter le parc existant nous
avons besoin de développer les énergies
nouvelles renouvelables et de doubler
notre parc installé d'ici à 2030 nous
avons besoin de poursuivre le
développement de notre filière nucléaire
avec de nouveaux réacteurs flamandville
Taishan incley point puis des réacteurs
qui seront construits en France pour
commencer le renouvellement du parc à
l'horizon 2030 et les décisions seront à
prendre vers 2020 et puis nous avons
aussi besoin d'investissement important
dans le réseau et vous qui êtes souvent
très proche du terrain dans les dans les
territoires vous savez bien qu'il y a
une forte demande pour la qualité de
service telle qu'elle est fournie par
notre filial ERDF qu'il y a des besoins
d'enfouissement qu'il y a des besoins de
raccordement d'énergie renouvelable et
puis il y a un programme particulier
dans lequel nous sommes engagés c'est
celui du compteur
Linky pour faire face à cette situation
la trajectoire financière que j'ai donc
présenté au conseil d'administration
vendredi dernier vise à sécuriser
l'avenir de DF dans un monde qui a
beaucoup changé qui est beaucoup plus
difficile qu'il qu'il ne l'était alors
quel est le contenu de ce plan d'abord
il s'agit d'optimiser nos
investissements ce n pas parce que nos
investissements sont indispensables
qu'il ne faut pas les les les les
optimiser et nous
avons établi que certains des
investissements qui se terminent je
pense à la rénovation des moyens de
production dans les îles comme la Corse
ou les les îles des départements
d'outremer je pense à la terminaison
proche à la terminaison prochaine de la
construction d'un terminal gazier à
dunkererc je pense à la construction de
notre magnifique campus de de saclé
voilà des programmes qui se terminent
voilà aussi des exemples
d'investissement que peut-être nous ne
lancerions plus aujourd'hui dans cette
conjoncture plus difficile et avec cette
plus forte sélectivité de nos
investissements mais tout en restant
avec la stratégie cap 2030 et bien nous
estimons pouvoir sur le périmètre
existant économiser environ 2 milliards
d'euros d'ici à 2018 et faire que nos
investissements sur le périmètre
existant passeront d'environ 12
milliards 7 à environ 10 milliards et
demi d'euros de 2015 à 2018 nous aurons
bien sûr des investissements nouveaux
qu'il faut poursuivre qui ne sont pas
dans ces chiffres tels que Linky tel que
flamville et
in nous n avons à réduire aussi nos
charges opérationnelles nous avons déjà
réduit nos coûts en 2015 c'est la
première fois depuis des années et des
années que DF réduisait ses charges
opérationnelles nous les avons réduit de
300 millions d'euros soit 1,4 % en en
2015 lors de la présentation des comptes
en février j'ai annoncé un objectif de
réduction de nos charges opérationnelles
de 700 millions d'euros en 2018 par
rapport à 2015 vendredi dernier en
conseil nous avons annoncé et et rendu
publicique quelques heures après que
nous portons cet objectif de 700
millions d'euros de réduction en 2018 à
au moins 1 milliard d'euros en 2019 donc
nous allons accentuer les efforts que
nous faisons sur nos charges
opérationnelles cependant je voudrais
souligner que comme nous l'avons partagé
avec les représentants du personnel en
début d'année nous serons amenés et
c'est assez logique à ne pas remplacer
tous les départs à la retraite à
développer la mobilité à cibler nos
recrutements sur les métiers en tension
et sur les métier au cœur de la
stratégie cap 2030 deedf par exemple
dans les métiers du numérique mais cette
évolution de l'emploi a été anticipé
puisque avec un souci d'organiser les
transferts de compétences entre les
générations qui partent à la retraite et
les générations qui rentrent dans
l'entreprise nous avons anticipé de
nombreux recrutements en début de la
décennie de la décennie 2010 afin
justement de faire d'organiser bien
cette transmission de compétences avec
beaucoup de de dépenses de formation et
donc comme je l'ai annoncé et donc il y
a quelques jours nous allons
euh diminuer les effectif de DF dans le
cadre des trajectoires que nous avions
partagé avec le CCE en janvier dernier
et non pas au-delà et je coupe ainsi
court à des rumeurs que nous allions
renforcer euh ces baisses d'effectifs il
y aura celle qui étaiit prévu en début
d'année mais nous ne prévoyons pas en
tout cas nous ne prévoyons pas
aujourd'hui d'aller d'aller plus loin 3è
élément de de notre plan pour sécuriser
notre trajectoire financière un plan de
cession d'actifs ce plan vise de à céder
des actifs pour environ 10 milliards
d'euros à l'horizon 2020 en consacrant
pardon en concentrant le périmètre deedf
sur nos actifs clés le plan de cession
inclut des participations minoritaires
il inclut des actifs de production
thermique hors de France et il inclut
aussi la concrétisation d'un chantier
que les les les de ministres de Bery ont
également annoncé en début en fin de
semaine dernière le chantier de
l'évolution du capital de RTE dont
aujourd'hui DF détient 100 % du capital
sans pouvoir assurer une gouvernance
normale il y aura des orientations
stratégique que le directoire de RTE est
en train de préparer nous aurons à
inscrire l'évolution du capital de RTE
dans ses orientations
stratégiques enfin la trajectoire
financière sécurisée de DF inclut un
rôle de l'État l'État en tant
qu'actionnaire et l'État en tant que
régulateur de du secteur vous l'avez dit
Monsieur le le
président EDF a fait part au conseil
d'administration de son intention de
proposer sur les années 2016 et 2017 une
option de versement des dividendes en
action et l'État a indiqué qu'il
retiendra cette option comme il l'a déjà
fait en 2015 puisque sur l'exercice 2015
le dividende que que l'État tire de DF
l'État le touche en titre et non pas en
cash donc cet argent 1 milliard 8
environ sur l'exercice 2015 reste dans
l'entreprise pour renforcer nos fonds
propres et améliorer notre équilibre
bilanciel d'autre part EDF soumettra à
son conseil d'administration d'ici la
clôture des comptes 2016 et sous réserve
des conditions de marché un projet
d'augmentation de capital d'environ 4
milliards d'euros et l'État a indiqué
qu'il souscrira à cette augmentation de
capital à la hauteur de 3 milliards
d'euros donc vous voyez que que par ces
deux mesures cell sur le dividende et
celle sur l'augmentation de capital
l'État actionnaire l'état investisseur
avisé accompagnera le groupe EDF dans
cette période d'investissement
stratégique mais l'État est aussi
régulateur et je voudrais terminer cette
présentation en vous disant quelques
mots sur le besoins indispensable que
nous avons d'adapter le modèle de
marché le modèle de marché actuel n'est
n'est pas durable tous les énergéticiens
européens sont en grande difficulté et
comme je le disais au début de mon
intervention EDF est plutôt parmi les
bien pants des électrices des
énergéticiens
européen aucun investissement
aujourd'hui ne se réalise sur le
territoire européen s'il n'est pas
subventionnés les prix de marché ne
permettent de justifier d'aucun
investissement il faut qu'il y ait des
interventions du régulateur pour que les
investissements notamment en matière
d'énergie renouvelable se se fassent
une évolution est donc nécessaire du
modèle de marché car la
régulation systématique des
investissements ne peut pas être la
seule réponse à la mise en concurrence
qui a été décidée il y a maintenant 20
ans des services de fourniture
d'électricité et d'ailleurs aussi de gaz
le la première nécessité c'est de donner
un prix minimum au carbone pour la
production d'électricité certains pays
comme le Royaume-Uni ou la Suède l'ont
déjà fait président de la République a
déclaré à la conférence environnementale
je crois que ça a été pris par la
ministre de l'environnement de l'énergie
et de la mer hier et à nouveau ce matin
président de la République a décidé
d'une démarche unilatérale de la France
je crois qu'il a même insisté sur le mot
unilatéral pour fixer un prix plancher
du CO2 afin d'entraîner d'autres pays
avec nous je crois que c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour la planète mais aussi pour
notre industrie et pour notre
groupe on voit que dans certains pays
voisins il continue à se faire de
nouveau de nouveaux investiss
dans des centrales au charbon ou au
ligit investissements qui sont fortement
polluants générateur de particules et
générateur de gaz à effet de serre et
ceci doit interpeller sur la cohérence
qu'il y a entre les objectifs qui sont
affichés et les politiques qui sont
réellement mises en place nous
considérons qu'un prix de 30 à 40 € la
tonne permettrait de remettre au bon
endroit dans l'ordre de mérite les
moyens de production en fonction de
leurs émissions et notamment de faire
passer les centrales au gaz devant les
centrales au charbon nous souhaitons
aussi que soit reconnue la valeur des
capacités de production nécessaires à la
sécurité d'approvisionnement c'est ce
qu'on appelle les les le marché de
capacité je voudrais vous dire que
d'après nos nos analyses en cas de grand
froid durable heureusement ça n'a pas
été le cas en 2016 pas plus qu'en 2015
ou 2014 mais nous avions eu en 2012 une
longue période de grand froid qui
touchait l'essentiel de l'Europe de
l'Ouest et nous pensons que tel que le
marché est organisé aujourd'hui et va
s'organisé nous ne pouvons pas garantir
c'est l'analyse de DF il y a aussi
l'analyse de RTE bien évidemment qui est
en charge de ce sujet mais l'analyse de
DF c'est que nous ne pouvons pas
garantir l'absence de blackout au vu des
fermetures de centrales non rentables
que tous les électriciens mettent en
œuvre dans ces marchés avec des prix
aussi déprimés le mécanisme de capacit
et donc nécessaire si on veut en
permanence fournir l'électricité à tous
les clients en cas de longue période de
grand froid enfin il faut aussi créer un
cadre régulatoire qui permettra que de
nouveaux investissements soi décidé
fondé sur des prix de marché puisque
comme je le disais tous les
investissements sont payés par une
garantie de prix de vente c'est-àdire
par l'augmentation de la facture des
clients finales dès aujourd'hui et ce
mécanisme n'est évidemment pas durable
en conclusion avant de répondre à vos
questions et je répondrai monsieur le
Président à vos questions plus précises
sur Inle point si vous le voulez bien
tout à l'heure en conclusion nous sommes
à un tournant en 70 ans puisque nous
avons fêté il y a quelques jours les 70
ans de DF nous avons construit pour la
collectivité nationale un parc de
production capable d'alimenter tous nos
clients de manière efficace en
électricité mais nous vivons une
transition énergétique une transition
numérique la définition de nouveaux
modèles de marché décentralisé et c'est
une nouvelle page qui va s'écrire pour
l'histoire du groupe EDF mon rôle c'est
de m'assurer queedf puisse poursuivre sa
mission nous sommes une grande
entreprise au service du public nous
sommes l'entreprise de service public
qui recueille le plus d'adhésion des
Français nous devons encore nous ancrer
davantage dans les territoires et nous
devons participer activement à la
réponse P que chacun attend en matière
d'enjeux climatique en matière de climat
sont des enjeux qui se posent à la
planète nous avons donc une stratégie et
je dirais que la trajectoire financière
que j'ai pu annoncer la semaine dernière
me permet de dire que nous avons aussi
désormais les moyens de remplir notre
mission et de tenir nos promesses voilà
monsieur le Président ce que je voulais
vous dire à titre préliminaire j'ai
peut-être été un peu long et et je m'en
excuse et puis je vais maintenant
répondre à vos questions merci monsieur
le Président je suis certain que vous
avez d'ailleurs répondu à l'avance à
certaines des questions qui peuvent être
posées qui néanmoins vont être peut-être
reformulé alors je rappelle les règles
hein 2 minutes j'ai quelqu'un à côté de
moi qui chrono chrono hein je crois que
si on veut tenir dans un temps qui soit
compatible avec nos différentes
contraintes euh il est absolument
indispensable alors euh alternativement
entre les différents groupes donc tout
d'abord
ladislasski ensuite Roland cour et un
intermède Maurice Vincent qui est membre
de la commission des finances et
rapporteur spécial de l'agence
participation de
l'État ah il aura 2 minutes aussi mais
c'est déjà bien 2 minutes n'est-ce pas
bien
allez merci Monsieur président monsieur
le
président concernant vos investissements
j'ai bien retenu vos chiffres vous les
avez pas tous annoncer d'ailleurs inclle
point 16 milliards je ne sais pas
combien à votre charge combien la charge
de votre partenaire chinois grand
carénage vous n avez dit 51 milliards je
pensais que le chiffre en interne chez
vous était déjà à 55 milliards vous
n'avez pas rappelé mais racheter
l'activité nucléaire d'Areva c'est 2,5
milliards enfin il y a un chiffre que
vous n'avez pas donné c'est l'état de
votre dette actuelle vous êtes à
37,3
milliards alors je suis ravi pour vous
que l'État actionnaire est accepté de
vous suivre dans une augmentation de
capital à hauteur de 3 milliards
l'addition n'y est pas même si certains
investissements comme les 51 milliards
du grand carénage c'est d'ici 2025 moi
je vous pose une question très simple
que je vous ai déjà posé une fois vous
prenez bien un partenaire pour Inle
point un partenaire chinois pourquoi
est-ce que dans cette facture colossale
du grand carénage vous ne prenez pas des
partenaires même français il y a déjà
cinq centrales nucléaires françaises où
vous n'êtes pas propriétaire à 100 % une
partie du ces centrales appartiennent à
des partenaires privés pourquoi pour
alléger votre dette vous n'ouvrez pas
une partie du capital pour le la
rénovation de vos réacteurs c'était ma
première question si j'ai le temps ma
deuxème renouvelable euh le renouvelable
vous avez bien dit que vous seriez
présent moi je vous rappelle ce que
vient d'annoncer le le Danemark je
prends exprès pour une fois pas
l'Allemagne en exemple le Danemark 50 %
de la production d'électricité vient de
l'éolien cri cri de toutes les
entreprises les entreprises danoises
paient leur électricité trois fois plus
cher que les entreprises françaises
est-ce que vous croyez pas qu'il faut
mettre un certain au
merci la parole est à Roland Courteau
ensuite Maurice Vincent merci monsieur
le Président oui concernant la la
décision de reporter de quelques mois
inclay point et de consulter le CCE je
dis elle est la bienvenue mais selon moi
le bon rapport devra être de 2 ou 3 ans
il semblerait en effet très risqué de
lancer l'opération dès maintenant c'est
aussi notamment la vie des syndicats et
il est largement partagé entendons-nous
bien il ne s'agit pas de renoncer mais
de reporter le projet pour mieux pour
mieux assurer sa réussite le lancer d
maintenant ne serait-il pas faire
prendre à EDF un risque existentiel et
je pèse bien mes mots conjoncture
dégradée euh contexte industriel qui
n'est pas favorable situation financière
deedf préoccupante achat d'ara grand
carénage euh modification du schéma de
participation et baisse de la
participation des Chinois euh question à
allez-vous persister ou bien reporter la
décision de 3 ans quant à l'argument
selon lequel si nous n'engageions pas
l'opération immédiatement le Royaume-Uni
pourrait se tourner vers d'autres
concurrents personnellement moi je n'y
crois pas d'abord parce que seul le Pr
est certifié par l'Autorité de sûreté
britannique ensuite seul EDF possède les
terrains préparés et l'autorisation de
construire donc il faudrait plusieurs
années à tout autre projet concurrent
n'y a-t-il pas monsieur président euh
d'autres priorités immédiates que inclé
point et enfin concernant l'Europe
quelle est véritablement votre stratégie
vous soullignez par ailleurs que vous
investissez beaucoup dans les énergies
renouvelables mais dans le même temps on
observe des ventes d'actifs d'énergie
renouvelable pourtant rentable et
parallèlement le groupe prend des
engagements dans de nouveaux projets
alors pouvez-vous nous
expliquer bien je remercie le président
court euh
qui n'a pas consommé son temps euh la
parole je peux continuer alors est à
Maurice c'est un encouragement limité la
parole est à Maurice Vincent ensuite à
Bruno sidau
oui merci monsieur le Président merci de
m'accueillir dans dans votre
commission monsieur le Président moi je
voudrais poser trois questions
rapidement concernant la dette qui est
une question importante 37 milliards
cela a été dit fin 2015 quel est le
quelles sont vos perspectives dans votre
plan financier à moyen terme comment euh
la voyez-vous évoluer puisqu'elle a
quand même augmenté de 8 % entre 2014 et
2015 la deuxème question c'est sur les
ventes d'actifs 10 milliards sont
annoncés j'ai pu lire dans la presse que
sur ces 10 milliards 6 milliards
seraient réalisé était envisagé en tout
cas sur 2016 est-ce que vous confirmez
ce chiffre ou ou pas et puis pour Inle
point qui est éid une question
importante sur il y a un engagement sur
les prix est-ce qu'il y a un engagement
sur les quantités achetées par le
Royaume-Uni je vous remercie bien merci
la parole est à Bruno sidau ensuite à
Franck
monteger merci monsieur le Président ma
question est très simple micro ma
question est très simple il est question
de plus en plus j'entendais encore
madame la ministre de l'Environnement ce
matin à la radio nous dire que
flamandville allait être fermé que fin
2016 euh les fin fa fa fa pas
ouver
ces mouvements divers sont pris sur le
temps de parole de Bruno Sid c'est très
court faitenheim donc fin 2016 les
décisions devraient être prise et cetera
vous avez fait des gros travaux prof
puisque les deux tranches ont été
rénovées et ma question est toute simple
est-ce que vous allez être
indemnisé de de ces travaux parce que
finalement soit vous auriez pu ne pas
les faire et fermer plus tôt et puisque
vous les avez fait que vous pensez
devoir les amortir je sais pas combien
de temps vous nous le direz d'ailleurs
allez-v indemnisé ça c'est la première
question et comment allons-nous
indemniser les Suisses et les Allemands
qui sont copropriétaires de cette
centrale bien merci Bruno sidau la
parole est à Franck monteger ensuite à
Sophie prima
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le Président Levi pour votre
exposé un regard rétrospectif sur les 15
dernières années nous amène à constater
que DF évolue dans le cadre d'un
processus de libéralisation impensée
impensée par l'État et les gouvernements
qui sont succédés comme par les
dirigeants de entreprise la situation
extrêmement préoccupante d'aujourd'hui
nous conforte dans ce sentiment qu'il
n'y a pas de vision pas de stratégie
suffisamment claire et partagé le
bradage du patrimoine public qui
illustre une nouvelle fois sous
l'impulsion de Bruxelles l'injonction de
libéralisation de la production
hydraulique atteste également du
processus de dépissage progressif d'un
des plus grands énergéticiens au monde
dans ce même secteur on a connu d'autres
entreprises et pas des moindres qui ont
disparu au terme de prise de décision
qui sont avéré au final hasarde EDF
n'est pas à l'abri et les grands pjet
don vous avez parlé qui sont autant de
prise de risque incle point en fait
partie pourrait accentuer ce processus
pour certains d'entre eux c'est cela
qu'il faut éviter en revenant aux
objectifs qui ont présidé il y a 70 ans
à la nationalisation des entreprises du
secteur de l'énergie de l'époque
indépendance énergétique de la France et
exportation égalité d'accès à une
électricité de qualité à des coûts
maîtrisés pour tous et sur tout le
territoire c'est la péréquation
tarifaire peu de sollicitations
financière de l' état sur longue période
modèle social exemplaire qui n'a pas peu
contribué au réussitees depuis 1945 tels
ont été les ingrédients de la réussite
et en définitive EDF a contribué de
façon essentielle majeure à la
compétitivité de notre économie à la
souveraineté nationale de la France et à
son rayonnement international le cap
industriel doit rester celui-là tout en
intégrant les enjeux de la transition
énergétique son respect dans la durée
suppose qu'État et gouvernement
s'opposent par tout moyen à la finan
isation des marchés de l'énergie vous
avez monsieur le Président évoqué ce
point en parlant du modèle de marché
actuel qui n'est pas durable là se situe
la question politique majeure dont la
réponse orientera le devenir de DF elle
se pose tout autant au niveau européen
que national la stratégie industrielle
de DF doit enêtre la déclinaison au
premier au bénéfice premierers ne
l'oublions pas des consommateurs et de
nos entreprises mercici merci Franck
monteger la parole est à Sophie prima et
ensuite à Marchal Bourquin merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président après ces questions très
stratégiques moi je voudrais ê terre à
terre à terre vous avez décidé de fermer
la centrale à fioule de porscheville euh
avec notamment la fermeture de deux
générateurs dès 2017 alors que la
décision de de fermeture était
2023 à l'origine je comprends les
caractéristiques financières
probablement très lourdes de ce site euh
j'ai quand même lever l'oreille tout à
l'heure quand vous avez parlé du marché
de capacité notamment pour faire face au
grand froid durable puisque cette
centrale n'était utilisée que dans ce
cas-là et que effectivement comp tenu de
la météo des deux dernières années elle
n'a pas été utilisée donc je comprends
la charge financière mais je comprends
aussi le rôle de cette centrale de
Porcheville donc mes questions sont là
aussi assez pragmatiqu je voulais savoir
quel était le poids en fait de cette
centrale de sécurité finalement par
rapport au blackout que vous évoqué tout
à l'heure le poids financier de cette
centrale dans vos résultats quels seront
comment vont être traités les les 200
employés EDF qui travaillent sur ce site
de porscheville quelles actions
avez-vous entreprises ou pensez-vous
entreprendre sur les très nombreux
prestataires de services qui travaillent
pour cette centrale il y en a dans l'un
de vallée de la scinene 130 de dénombré
et puis ensuite en tant qu'élu aussi de
ce territoire quelles sont les pistes de
reconversion de ce site de 90 hactares
aux portes du port de Limet que vous
envisagez y compris éventuellement dans
la transition énergétique avez-vous des
projets dans ce sens merci merci
beaucoup bien merci Sophie prima la
parole est à Marcial Bourquin ensuite
Daniel Dubois merci monsieur le
Président de de cette exposé trois
questions simples vous n'avez pas abordé
la question des déchets et du
démantelllement des
central pouvez-vous
l'aborder dans les réponses aux
questions
avec le prix que ça représente parce que
il y a eu des articles dans le monde et
dans la la presse économique nous disant
que les prix pourraient exploser sur ces
questions deuxème chose euh 3500 poste
supprimé est-ce que ça sera au détriment
de la présence
territoriale vous savez que la présence
territoriale de ce grand énergéticien
qui est EDF est une question essentielle
et euh pouvez-vous nous préciser je
trouve que la note est salée euh et
est-ce qu'il est possible de revenir en
arrière sur ces suppressions d'emploi
3è question recherche fondamentale et
appliquée vous avez parlé beaucoup du
nucléaire des énergies renouvelables
est-ce que la recherche continue sur
l'hydrogène sur les énergies de demain
avec la question du numérique on sait
qu'il va y avoir de véritables
révolutions dans matière de l'énergie
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en parler
plus précisément merci bien merci Mar
Bourquin la parole est
à
Dani bois et ensuite à Delphine bataille
merci
président monsieur le Président moi j'ai
une seule question vous nous avez
préciser que vous aviez bâti un plan
stratégique à
2030 vous avez une production
d'électricité qui est à 75 % nucléaire
je ne peux imaginer que vous ayez bâti
ce plan sans naturellement penser les
fermeturesouis d'un certain nombre de
centrales donc combien et avez-vous des
assurances de l'État ouais sur ce nombre
de
fermeture bien merci Daniel Dubois la
parole et donc à Delphine bataille et
ensuite à ellizabeth Lamur merci
monsieur le président parmi les actions
de désendettement de DF annoncé un plan
de cession à hauteur de 10 milliards
d'euros dont 50 % de RTE pour 3
milliards et demi et l'évolution après
le dernier conseil d'administration fait
apparaître une part de RTE avant 2016 je
voudrais savoir si vous nvez si vous
pouvez pardon nous préciser maintenant à
quoi correspond cette part ainsi que son
montant vous avez également évoqué un
plan d'économie qui augmente la
réduction des charges opérationnelles à
1 milliard d'euros au lieu des 700
millions initialement prévus est-ce que
vous pouvez nous indiquer les modalités
et le
calendrier de ce plan vous comprendrez
nos inquiétudes sur la solidité
financière de DF qui aura aussi à
supporter le le poids d'Areva vous avez
évoqué un certain nombre de charges à
venir et je voudrais pour ma part
revenir sur CGO puisque le dernier devis
officiel prévoit un renchérissement du
cout ce sont 25 milliards d'euros pour
ODF je voudrais savoir comment vous avez
prévu de répondre en terme d'échéancier
et quel sera le montant du
provisionnement immédiat enfin comment
envisagez-vous les perspectives en terme
de coût de l'énergie compte tenu
aujourd'hui du niveau des prix et dans
un contexte où il est difficile de
démontrer la pertinence du nucléaire par
rapport au prix des autres énergies par
exemple le baril du pétrole est-ce que
vous pensez que la notion de durée est
suffisamment prise en compte dans nos
débats publics je m'explique aujourd'hui
l'objectif de la loi qui fixe à 50 % la
part du nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité en moins ans semble
illusoire pour beaucoup d'entre nous en
raison de cette durée parfois mal
apprécié et aussi au regard de la durée
de vie des centrales quel est votre avis
sur la prolongation en terme de durée de
vie des centrales merci merci Delphine
bataille la parole é Élisabeth Lamur
ensuite Yannick vugrenard merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Président
j'aurais une question qui porte sur
l'hydraulique vous avez dit que vous
souhaitiez optimiser votre potentiel
hydraulique et en effet fait DF gère je
crois 80 %
du du parc hydraulique de de notre pays
or vous savez que la Commission
européenne s'impatiente sur la mise en
concurrence des concessions
hydroélectriques je ne sais pas si les
appels d'offres ont été lancés en tout
cas c'est quelque chose qui dure depuis
2008 lorsque les appels d'offres seront
là est-ce que EDF entend être candidate
pour la gestion de ces des concessions
qu'elle qu'elle exploite aujourd'hui et
puis dans le prolongement une question
concernant la redevance hydraulique qui
a donc été mise en place en 2006 elle
est importante parce qu'elle représente
24 ou 25 % du du chiffre
d'affaires et il semblerait que EDF ne
s'acquitte pas de cette redevance et que
seul la CNR la compagnie nationale du rô
les fait or ce sont des montants qui
sont extrêmement importants tant pour
l'État que pour les collectivités
puisque c'est un partage à 5050 et cela
représente plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros est-ce que vous pouvez
nous répondre sur ce point je vous
remercie merci Elisabeth Lamur la parole
à Yan vugrenard ensuite Philippe Leroi
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur Levi de la
présentation particulièrement complète
et détaillée que vous nous avez fait ce
qui vous permet d'avoir des informations
très très très très importantes vous
l'avez souligné DF est exemplaire dans
dans beaucoup de domaines et d'abord je
pense que le fait que DF a été créé
voici 70 ans vous l'avez rappelé par le
Conseil National de la Résistance le
fait que la participation de l'État soit
hauteur de 85 % c'est la conséquence
aujourd'hui c'estelle cause probablement
aujourd'hui du fait que notre
indépendance nationale énergétique est
préservée le la conséquence la cause
également le le le le fait que le prix
de de de l'électricité est moins
important en France qu'ailleurs vous
l'avez souligné et pour le particulier
et pour nos entreprises cependant il y a
nous sommes un tournant vous l'avez
souligné vous êtes montré rassurant dans
le détail également sur le contrat avec
in Inle
point
cependant le fait d'être rassurant
n'empêche pas d'avoir aussi un certain
nombre d'inquiétude pourquoi parce que
Flamanville le père de Flamanville à
plusieurs reprises a vu une augmentation
très forte de son coût et euh vous nous
avez annoncé que cela devraitêtre mis en
œuvre le 4e trimestre 2018 2018 pardon
quand serait-il s'il y avait d'une part
prolongation de cette mise en œuvre de
flamandville et d'autre part si c'était
encore plus coûteux quelle conséquence
cela pourrait avoir sur l'investissement
éventuel de en Angleterre il ne faudrait
pas en effet que le père de de
flamandville devienent en quelque sorte
si je puis m'exprimer ainsi le Concorde
de l'énergie françise et pour cela il
nous faut beaucoup de de prudence enfin
deè question sur le stockage de
l'énergie on en parle souvent je crois
que c'est l'alpha l'oméga de l'énergie
de demain y a-t-il des recherches
collaboratives avec l'ensemble des pays
de l'Union européenne merci Yanni
vrenard la parole est à Philippe Leroi
et ensuite à Jo Lab prière question
c'est la même que celle
de pouro pas
attendre la certitude de terminer
flamandville avec une sécurité financiè
sur le plan des
essais des essais techniques en cours
pourquoi ne pas attendre tout cela ça
serait peut-être prudent dans le cadre
d'une stratégie que je partage
d'ailleursedf si on veut rester sur le
marché mondial dans la construction des
centrales nucléaair il faut espérer que
Flav enville puisse marcher mais on en
est pas encore sûr donc pourquoi ne pas
attendre un peu par prudence
deuxème question vous n'avez pas parlé
des énergies renouvelables mais je suis
assez heureuse que vous ne parliez pas
de la biomasse EDF ne semble pas avoir
de projet dans la biomasse et c'est et
c'est assez heureux dans la mesure où
votre confrère Eton s'est lancé dans un
projet
pharaonique à Tarascon si j'ai bonne
mémoire
ou Gardane est en train de de détruire
bien des espoirs pour la filière VO donc
cuid de la biomasse et merci peut-être
de ne pas en parler ou de ne pas en
faire trisème question
euh le grand carénage
EDF a-t-il bien
imaginer l'association de de l'économie
locale le développement local à
l'occasion des chantiers de grand
carénage à l'image de ce qui a été fait
pour les stratégies grand chantier quand
on construisait les les centrales je
sais que chez moi DF a largement
contribué au développement d'entreprise
local au moment de la construction de
catenom et cuid du carénage bien merci
Philippe loroi la parole est à Joel Labé
ensuite Gérard bailli oui merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Président Lévi
euh merci d'abord de de de de de votre
exposé de venir vous exposer je vous
trouve très serein étant donné les
enjeux mais je crois que dans votre
position vous vous devez d'être serein
beaucoup de questionnements quand même
n'oublions pas n'oublions pas que on est
au lendemain de l'anniversaire de de la
terrible catastrophe de Tchernobyl euh
d'une part alors on a parlé
démentantellement notre collègue martial
burquin vous Vous annoncez à juste titre
qu'on produit actuellement une
électricité abondante et au moins chè de
de par rapport par rapport à nos voisins
pour ma part et pour notre part nous
estimons que le prisionnement pour les
les futurs démantellements quels que
soient les délais euh successif qu'on
qu'on va devoir financer euh parlez-nous
un petit peu des desprisionnements et
des garanties que vous avez sur le fait
que c'est c'est c'est démantellement
successifs je veux parler à 10 20 30 ans
ça va commencer avant 10 ans d'ailleurs
pour les premières d'une part d'autre
part derrière cela l'avenir enfin votre
société a un avenir aussi dans le
démantelllement de par un certain
savoir-faire et une véritable économie
dans le démentantèlement sur le
territoire français comme à l'étranger
si vous voulez nous donner quelques
précisions un deuxième point qui
pourrait paraître plus léger mais qui a
son importance on avait longuement
débattu sur les ZNI les zones non
interconnectées avec très peu d'enjeux
les petites îles notamment à moins de
200 à moins de 2000 clients donc je sais
que EDF était intervenu pour que pour
que la majorité obtenue ne ne puisse pas
être renouvelée alors pour le moment pu
puisque ces zones non interconnectées
n'ont pas de statut particulier est-ce
que vous seriez à même de déléguer à de
petits opérateurs pour mettre en place
véritablement en bénéficiant de la CSPE
des projets collaboratifs des projets
innovants des
projets expérimentaux dont on aura
besoin au plan national et aussi au plan
international Jo Lab la parole est à
Gérard bi ensuite Jean-Pierre bzinau oui
on constat les accidents climatiques se
font de plus en plus nombreux je pense
ces dernières décennies voir ces
dernières années tempêtes coup de vent
neige orage et aujourd'hui on sait quand
on a plus d'électricité toute la vie
économique s'arrête c'est peut-être
encore plus important qu'ier d'avoir des
dépanages rapides alors un inquiétude
d'abord qu'on ne diminue pas bien c'est
les gens qui font les réparations pour
je crois que M que le terrain en a
besoin et très rapidement c'est un
souhait que que je voudrais que j'aimis
en cet instant deè 2ème question aussi
c'est par
rapport des bruits qui ont été courus
que on il y aurait les effacement des
jours de pointe le JP pourriez-vous nous
rassurer là-dessus et pouvoir dédire
parce que je sais que dans secteur où je
suis l'agriculture on a beaucoup de
séchagant grandange l'été AC beaucoup à
le JP et qu'à ce moment-là l'hiver font
des économies ces jours-là ne consomment
pas d'électricité donc c'est important
en terme aussi de dans ma région de
séchage d'été où on a beaucoup besoin
d'énergie au moment il y en a pas besoin
ailleurs alors est-ce que l' JP va se
poursuivre troisème chose vous avez
parlé d'Ikea est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner plus de précision on l'avait
juste évoquer et 4e et dernière euh la
bourse aujourd'hui le je crois que c'est
à 12 € au lieu que c'était à 32 est-ce
quelles sont les incidences est-ce qu'il
va pas y avoir là un manque de confiance
aussi des différentes personnes est-ce
que ça peut poser des problèmes bien
entendu sur et quelles sont les
répercussions qui peut y avoir cette
diminution importante des cours de
bourse EDF bien merci Gérard baayer la
parole est à Jean-Pierre bzinot ensuite
Daniel
gréiller merci Messieurs les
Présidents Franck Montauger l' l'a
évoqué je à mon tour juste un mot sur
les 70 ans de DF je je ne suis pas
certain que ils doivent être très peu
mais parmi ceux qui ont participé à la
libération à la création de cette grande
entreprise qui était EDF GDF il soi très
fier de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui et
et de de de ce qu'on a fait de cette
entreprise je veux le dire parce que
effectivement on est à l'inverse de ce
qui était leur démarche du bien commun
on a beaucoup parlé vous nous avez
beaucoup parlé monsieur le Président
Lévi de stratégie de trajectoire
financière moins de stratégie
industrielle et je pense qu'il serait
utile que vous nous précisiez un certain
nombre de choses de ce point de vue et
en particulier vous avez évoqué les
économies qui vont passer de cette 100
millions à 1 milliard euh et donc des
des suppressions d'emploi hein puisque
euh le fait de non de ne pas renouveler
des des départs c'est sont des
suppressions d'emploi quelle est la
répartition euh si vous l'avez euh des
des suppressions d'emplois euh parce que
moi j'ai une inquiétude en particulier
sur les emplois qui concernent la
recherche et le développement mais aussi
euh la production euh la production euh
directe et puis une dernière chose euh
votre prédécesseur monsieur progliot en
2014 nous déclarait que cette grande loi
qu'on appelle la loi Nome euh oblige EDF
à vendre un/4 de sa production euh en
dessous le prix de revien à ses
concurrents qu'en est-il aujourd'hui
puisque de fait euh ça aboutissait à
subventionner des concurrents euh
d'EDF bien merci jean-perre bzinot la
parole est à Daniel grber ensuite à alin
Durand
oui merci président euh une première
remarque je voudrais monsieur le
Président vous remercier de de votre
propos parce qu'il contribue rapporter
la confiance et lorsqu'on est dans le
champ concurrentiel il est vraiment
important d'avoir cette
confiance j'ai que deux questions
simples la première vous avez pas du
tout abordé le prix du baril qui d'après
le monde pétrolier s'instalent quand
même dans des niveaux très bas en terme
de concurrence c'est un questionnement
et ma deième
question c'est ma curiosité d'en savoir
plus sur votre stratégie sur
RTE on connaît l'échec de la SNCF et de
RFF on connaît l'importance et la
réussite qui a été EDF sur l'ensemble du
territoire et effectivement quand je
j'entends votre propos je voudrais en
savoir un peu plus merci merci Grier la
parole est àain dur ensuitene Catherine
oisier merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Lévi vous avez
évoqué dans vos propos vos ambitions
fortes je cite en matière d'énergie
renouvelable et l'hydroélectricité fait
partie de ces énergies donc je voudrais
revenir sur les concessions
hydroélectriques et plus
particulièrement sur la mise en demeure
faite à la France par l'Union Européen
le 22 octobre dernier afin d'ouvrir la
les concessions hydroélectriques à la
concurrence au de le renouvellement
alors certes si l' envoie d'une lettre
de mise en demeure ne préjuge pas de la
conclusion finale de la procédure par
contre la procédure permet à la
commission d'entamer un dialogue actif
avec les autorités don monsieur le
Président pouvez-vous nous préciser où
en sont aujourd'hui ces discussions
entre la commission l'État et et votre
entreprise et toujours sur le même sujet
au mois d'août dernier dans la loi de
transition énergétique un nouveau
dispositif d'ouverture des concessions
permet également de repousser ces
échances à la mesure où des travaux
importants seront pris seront entrepris
dans les ouvrages compte tenu du
contexte et et des zones de turbulences
qui ont été rappelé depuis le début et
que traversent vutre entreprisees vous
prévoyez de réduireos les
investissements et de les ramener à 10
milliards contre 15 aujourd'hui
pouvez-vous nous préciser monsieur le
Président où iront vos priorités est-ce
que les 435 centrales hydroélectriques
et les 622 barrages que contre que
contre notre pays seront impactés par
ces baisses ce sont des interrogations
en tout cas qui préoccupent les
habitants de de nallé qui vivent avec
depuis très longtemps avec
l'hydroélectricité qui reste une filière
d'excellence merci alain Durant
catherineisier a la parole et ensuite
Serge Larcher oui merci président donc
ma question va à peu près dans dans le
même sens à savoir quelle est votre
stratégie en en matière de développement
des des ressources de production durable
et plus précisément donc quelles sont
les perspectives d'évolution dans la
répartition des des différentes énergies
renouvelables au sein de votre
production bien merci anne- Catherine
noisier Serge Larcher a la parole et
ensuite Dominique Estrosi merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Président lesv
vous avez fait part de votre volonté de
développer des solutions décentralisées
c'est dans ce cadre là je voudrais vous
poser une question concernant le projet
de construction d'une centrale gé
thmique dans l'île de de la de la
Dominique projet porté à la fois par les
deux conseil par le Conseil Régional de
la Martinique conseil régional de la
Guadeloupe je cite je rappelle que l' la
Dominique se situe entre les deux îles
et nous dépendons fortement aujourd'hui
ça bienent de des desénergie fossile et
ce qui revient que à faire ce qui ce qui
fait que l'énergie coûte très cher dans
ces îles qui sont non
connectées bien merci Serge Larcher la
parole est à Dominique estri ensuite à
ivrom oui merci monsieur le Président
vous nous avez dit que vous aviez
anticipé de nombreux
recrutements au début de la décennie de
l'année 2010 je voudrais me référer à un
rapport de la Cour des comptes de mars
2016 qui souigne que les projets
industriels DDF dans le nucléaire
nécessiteront 110000 recrutement d'ici
2020 en emploi direct et indirect dont
70000 emplois de niveau Bac pro à bac +
3 alors qu'on sait que les 2/ers des des
entreprises de la filière ont beaucoup
de mal à recruter dans certains métiers
pense à la robinetterie tuyoterie
soudage bureau d'étude et dans ce
rapport de la Cour des comptes il est
également écrit que vous avez aussi
identifier une faiblesse de la ressource
d'encadrement essentiellement contte
tenu des dél de formation qui sont
particulièrement longs est-ce que vous
pourriez nous préciser un peu plus votre
stratégie en matière
d'emploi bien merci domiguz revi la
parole est à yvrom oui très rapidement
monsieur le Président j'aimerais vous
l'avez évoqué partiellement connaître
votre stratégie par rapport à la
numérisation de la société nous sommes
en train d'examiner un texte sur la
République numérique je voudrais
connaître quelle est la stratégie d'EDF
par rapport aux objets connectés dont on
nous annonce des dizaines des dizaines
de milliards d'objets à l'intérieur de
nos habitations et également connaître
votre position par rapport à aux
sollicitations nombreuses dont nous
sommes l'objet par rapport euh aux
électrosensible sur le compteur
Linky merci la parole est à François
Calvet oui moi je voudrais juste poser
une question pour savoir quel est l'état
de fonctionnement et la rentabilité des
interconnexions électriques notamment
avec l'Espagne avec la THT nouvelle que
vous avez fait passer depuis euh qui
part de l'UD
et qui traverse les pyénes orientales et
qui va jusqu'à au Pertus et comment
comment ça ça se passe et quel est les
échanges avec l'Espagne s'il sont
fructueux bien on a terminé avec ma
dernière question qui est en fait la
suivante concernant fait monsieur le
Président l'Autorité de sûreté nucléaire
a accordé 10 ans supplémentaires qui
nous pousse à au-delà de 2020 est-ce
qu'il est cohérent aujourd'hui de la
part du gouvernement de demander la
fermeture
de réacteurs qui ont justement fait
l'objet d'une validation par l'autorité
de sreté nucléaire quel serait l'impact
financier il y a un rapport
parlementaire ENF de l'Assemblée
nationale un rapport bipartisan qui
chiffre à 4 milliards d'euros le montant
de ce qui devrait être versé DF est-ce
que vous pouvez confirmer ce chiffre
enfin en ce qui concerne la réduction de
la part du nucléaire le gouvernement
semble vouloir diminuer euh dans les
années qui viennent le nombre de
réacteurs en service alors je vous
demande pas de me donner la liste des
réacteurs qui seraient
euh désigné mais quels sont selon vous
les critères qui pourraient être pris en
compte est-ce que notamment celui de
l'âge du réacteur enfin si vousz
autoriser concernant RTE j'aimerais que
vous soyez plus précis la loi est très
claire elle dit que RTE doit être à 100
% publique
alors est-ce que par rapport à cette
obligation vous avez des informations
qui laissent à penser qu'on sortirait de
la sphère publique si on ne sort pas bon
est-ce que passer d'une poche à l'autre
sur le même costume change beaucoup
l'équilibre financier de l'opération
voilà monsieur le Président vous avez
beaucoup de vous félicite les uns et les
autres y compris mon intervention qui
qui s'est tenue dans le cadre que j'ai
que j'ai que j'ai fixé 33 minutes et il
y a eu 22
interventions
bien 22 interventions auxquelles je vais
essayer de répondre d'abord en vous
remerciant de de vos questions je suis
un peu confus parce qu'elles sont très
diverses et alors les rassembler en
elles sont diverses oui les rassembler
essayer de donner une réponse un peu
construite ne va pas être facile donc je
vous prie à l'avance de de de m'excuser
si je n'arrive pas
à à donner une réponse complètement
structurée en tout cas peut-être je vais
je vais commencer par les sujets le
président leoir avait commencé par cela
autour d'Inle
point président Lenoir
et un autre des des sénateurs ici
présent a en effet posé la question
d'abord de la garantie de volume hein cl
point alors je voudrais dire que nous
sommes doublement garantis nous sommes
garantis sur le prix mais nous sommes
doublement garantis sur le volume nous
avons une première garantie qui est dans
le marché dans le mode de fonctionnement
du marché britannique donc c'est une
garantie générique sur la priorité
donnée au au aux installations de base
hein puisque le nucléaire bien
évidemment fonctionne en base et puis
nous avons une deuxième garantie sur nos
volumes qui est dans le contrat pour
différence que nous avons de cette fois
de façon spécifique au projet inclle
point négocié avec le gouvernement
britannique et qui est à l'intérieur
donc de ce contrat pour différence donc
nous n'avons pas de souci que nous
arriverons non seulement à produire à
vendre au prix qui a été convenu
contractualisé enfin qu'il est le projet
et que le contrat soit signé bientôt
mais aussi à écouler sur le marché nos
volumes parce que c'est un souci tout à
fait naturel la question que vous vous
posez nous nous l'étions posé nous avons
donc une une réponse en ce qui concerne
les les les autres sujets sur sur inclay
point le partage des risques oui nous
avons deux actionnaires à par à part
égal enfin avec un niveau de risque à
peu près équivalent qui sont EDF pour
les 2 tiers et les Chinois pour 1/ers et
d'ailleurs je répondrai sur les chiffres
du du sénateur poniatovski incle point
est au total un chantier qui va coûter
environ allez ça dépend un petit peu du
du taux livre euros mais mettons qu'il
coûte environ 24 milliards milliards
d'euros les Chinois nos partenaires de
CGN vont en apporter le tiers 8
milliards et nous nous allons mettre en
effet 16 milliards d'euros mais ce
projet a déjà commencé depuis plusieurs
années donc nous n'avons pas devant nous
la totalité des 24 milliards d'euros à
dépenser mais peut-être avons-nous
dépenser déjà 10 ou 15 % de de de de
cette somme alors nous avons en effet
prévu un partage des risques mais dans
la mesure où EDF est
le maître d'ouvrage puisque nous nous
sommes à la fois celui qui va fournir le
réacteur et celui qui va l'exploiter à
travers cette filiale nous avons mis en
place des système
incitatif pour que le le le le EDF soit
un petit peu récompensé du travail qu'il
a déjà fait et EDF soit un peu pénalisé
s'il est en retard mais ces montants
sont tout à fait minimes ils n'ont rien
à voir avec le montant qu'il s'agit
d'investir donc le le le si si si les
choses se passent bien nous pourrions
investir 1 ou 2 % de moins euh par
rapport aux Chinois si les choses se
passent mal 1 ou 2 % de plus c'est juste
un mécanisme incitatif mais il est de de
de faible ampleur donc je réponds aussi
ainsi à la à la question sur sur le
partage de risque sur la durée de de
réalisation il est clair que c'est un
grand projet et que nous
avons mis toutes les chances de nos
côtés de notre côté pour le réaliser au
bon moment et et notamment en tenant
compte de façon essentielle de des
leçons que nous apprenons chaque jour
sur Flamanville en particulier et et
aussi sur tishan puisque nous avons des
dizaines de représentants de DF et
d'Areva qui sont présents aujourd'hui en
Chine pour la construction et
aujourd'hui ce sont plutôt les essais la
construction est à peu près achevée de
euh de taan donc nous mettons toutes les
chances de notre côté je voudrais
souligner puisque j'avais j'avais des
des des questions là-dessus euh que euh
le le les délais sont un sujet tout à
fait euh tout à fait essentiel notamment
monsieur Philippe Leroi vous vous disiez
il faudrait attendre flamandville mais
c'est ce que nous avons faitin puisque
le chantier d'incley point va commencer
en
2019 la phase que nous lançons
aujourd'hui est une phase dans lequelle
nous lançons les constructions des
différents équipements qui sont les
mêmes qu'à qu'à flamandville sauf pour
la sauf pour la cuve et puis ce sont
surtout des phases d'études et des
phases propres au sitite d'inklep parce
que par exemple pour vous donner un
exemple le canal de Bristol dans lequel
nous allons aller chercher l'eau il a
des caractéristiques notamment l'eau est
assez boueuse qui nous oblige à faire
des travaux spécifiques sur inlepo et
que nous n'avons pas à faire sur
flamandville ou dans le côentin l'eau
est beaucoup plus pure voilà et donc les
travaux que nous avons à faire sont
essentiellement des études des travaux
de terrassement des travaux de
préparation de chantier et l'agencement
des choses fait que en décidant incle
point maintenant le chantier de
construction du bâtiment nucléaire
d'inkcle point démarra quand nous aurons
terminé les essais de celui de
Flamanville c'est-à-dire en 2019 et donc
nous avons aujourd'hui une une très
bonne continuité dans la gestion de nos
compétences si nous si nous retardons
comme certains le demandent le chantier
de de de Flamanville l'un des
inconvénients c'est que nous allons à
nouveau avoir une rupture dans les
chantiers puisque le chantier de
construction d'inkle point le premier
béton de sûreté donc la partie la plus
difficile les les les l'encein de de
bâtiment nucléairire et toutes ces
constructions à l'intérieur du bâtiment
nucléaire sont retardé alors de 2 ans de
3 ans je ne sais pas peut-être jamais
non plus hein mais seront retardés par
rapport à la fin de de Flamanville donc
il faut voir que la décision que nous
voulons prendre aujourd'hui sur inley
point ce ce ce cale au niveau du
calendrier du mieux possible par rapport
à l'achèvement de de Flamanville et bien
sûr les équipes participent en
permanence les équipes de d'Inle point
et les équipes de
de Flamanville participe en permanence
les unes avec les autres à ce qu'on
appelle le retour le retour
d'expérience la durée de réalisation
mais nous nous sommes fixés des
objectifs à l'intérieur de ces objectifs
nous avons mis des provisions nous avons
prévu des alléas un chantier comme
celui-là on se contente pas de dire on
devrait faire tel jour ou telle semaine
telle tâche on fait l'addition et puis
voilà le planning non par définition en
tant que responsable industriel on met
des aléas est-ce que ces aléas sont trop
importants est-ce qu'ils sont justes
est-ce qu'ils sont insuffisants et bien
l'avenir le dira mais nous avons mis des
provisions financières des provisions de
délais en matière de d'Ala qui nous
sembleent respecter la meilleure
appréciation que l'on peut faire des
risques de dérapage et puis nous avons
aussi et nous l'avons fait dans le cadre
du conseil d'administration communiqué
les éléments financiers qui conduisent à
mesurer s'il y a encore des des aléas
supplémentaires au-delà des aléas qui
sont déjà prévus et nous avons démontré
que la rentabilité du projet en fait
elle est à peine écornée par un des
délais supplémentaires pourquoi parce
que la rentabilité du projet se fait par
les 35 ans de prix garanti et qu'un
décalage de prix de construction c'est
désagréable mais ça n bouleverse pas
cela ne modifie que légèrement
l'équilibre financier du projet ce qui
fait l'équilibre financier du projet
c'est les 35 ans de prix garanti et
c'est un point qui est donc tout à fait
euh tout à fait euh tout à fait
essentiel je voudrais peut-être euh
parler maintenant des des sujet
euh sur la programmation des centrales
nucléaires vous avez été nombreux à m'en
parler monsieur Dubois euh le président
euh le Président leoir Monsieur
Vaugrenard aussi un petit peu à travers
les conséquences
euh sur euh Flamanville euh
euh je je dirais que Monsieur courte
avait aussi un petit peu évoqué ce sujet
en parlant aussi de de de de Flamanville
je voudrais vous dire que les choses vu
de DF sont extrêmement claires la
représentation nationale a voté une loi
euh le gouvernement met en place les les
textes d'application et EDF
entreprise implanté en France applique
les lois de de la République la loi Pr
voit la fermeture de fessonheim lorsque
flamandville est mise en service nous
serons donc à fermer fessonheim lorsque
flamonville sera mise en service et le
Gouvernement a souhaité que le
dispositif qui conduira à cette
fermeture qui est donc à l'horizon de la
fin 2018 hein la mise en service de de
flamandville 3 fin 2018 que ce
dispositif soit préparé et bouclé si
vous me permettez l'expression dès cette
année 2006 16 le gouvernement a demandé
de préparer les les les différentes
étapes dès cette année 2016 alors quels
sont ces étape et bien il y a l'étape
actuelle dans lequel nous nous avons
engagé depuis quelques semaines madame
Segolen Royal a désigné il y a 5 ou 6
semaines un négociateur sur
l'indemnisation et l'étape actuelle
c'est que nous avons ouvert des
discussions entre DF et le négociateur
du ministère de l'Environnement nous
avons ouvert des discussions sur
l'indemnité en effet la
question est si je puis dire s'impose il
y a un préjudice subi par EDF du fait de
la privation cor EDF lors de la
fermeture d'un outil nucléaire qui comme
certains l'ont souligné fonctionne bien
sur lequel l'Autorité de sûreté
nucléaire a
donné des des autorisations qui
dépassent la date à laquelle il est
prévu qu'il s'arrête de par la loi et
donc le préjudice qui est je crois
indiscutable N nécessite d'être chiffré
ces discussions vont se poursuivre
j'imagine dans les jours et les semaines
qui viennent et puis lorsque la
l'indemnisation aura été discutée entre
l'État et et et EDF nous aurons à ce
moment-là à préparer l'approbation par
le conseil d'administration d'EDF de
cette convention entre l'État et et EDF
et à préparé ce que Madame Royal a
annoncé c'est-à-dire le retrait
d'autorisation d'exploitation qu'elle
voudrait qu'elle a demandé pour le
président de la République je crois l'a
dit aussi à la à la conférence
environnementale lundi dernier il est
prévu que ceci soit fait au mois de
décembre donc nous nous inscrivons dans
un calendrier dans lequel nous discutons
actuellement de l'indemnisation et puis
dans une deuxème étape nous préparerons
l'approbation par le conseil
d'administration cette approbation
devant d'abord faire l'objet d'un examen
par les différentes instances
représentatives du personnel concerné
puisque il s'agit d'une décision qui a
des des conséquences sociales il n'y a
pas de doute et que donc il y aura
de de de notre part à préparer les
réponses aux questions que vont
immanquablement se poser les
représentants du personnel sur
euh sur ce sujet sur la suite des
opérations et bien nous nous avons
aujourd'hui la partie renouvelable de la
PPE et EDF s'inscrit clairement dans euh
l'accélération de cette de ces
investissements en en France euh nous
avons je vais peut-être répondre
d'ailleurs à Monsieur courtau en effet
une politique affirmée de construction
de nombreuses installations de
nombreuses infrastructures éoliennes ou
sola mais aussi une politique de cession
de certains de ces actifs car pour des
raisons d'équilibre de notre bilan nous
ne gardons pas dans notre patrimoine la
totalité des fermes éoliennes ou des
fermes solaires que nous construisons
nous en vendons une partie à des
investisseurs qui ont un intérêt à
eux-même à revendre ces produits
financiers très prévisibles à à d'autres
catégories d'épargnant et le rôle de DF
je crois qu'on peut s'accorder là-dessus
c'est plutôt de construire pour nous
tous pour la planète de construire un
maximum de moyens d'énergie décarbonée
d'électricité décarbonée mais pas
nécessairement dans une période où nous
avons vous l'avez les uns et les autres
souligné beaucoup d'endettements pas
nécessairement de garder la totalité des
installations que nous construisons donc
nous en gardons certaines nous en
exploitons beaucoup nous avons créé des
emplois pour la maintenance de ces
installations que nous avons construites
mais assez fréquemment en effet Monsieur
Courteau nous nous les nous les vendons
alors ça c'est sur la partie
renouvelable de la PPE programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie sur la partie
nucléaire de la programmation
pluriannuel de l'énergie nous avons
compris des moi j'ai compris des
dernières déclarations qui ont été é
faite par le gouvernement que d'ici au
1er juillet une programmation de la
partie nucléaire et et peut-être
d'ailleurs des autres actifs sera
présenté par le gouvernement en
consultation notamment au Conseil
supérieur de l'énergie et nous aurons à
ce moment-là à chez EDF à regarder ce
que les différents scénarios qui nous
seront présentés veulent dire
et à préparer ce que sera l'application
de cette PPE nucléaire si on on peut
l'appeler comme ça au parc nucléaire de
DF à l'horizon 2010 à partir de
l'horizon 2018-219 puisque c'est à
l'horizon 2018-29 que devrait commencer
à si je peux dire qu'on pourra mesurer
l'évolution des différents scénarios
quant à la croissance de la la
consommation
d'électrique la production d'énergie
renouvelable la production d'énergie
nucléaire les exportations qu'il ne faut
pas oublier puisqu'il y a il y a des
exportations et et nous aurons à ce
moment-là à nous
inscrire dans cette dans cette PPE donc
n'attendez pas de DF un
travail détaillé sur le parc de centrale
nucléaire et et la traduction locale de
ce qui pourrait se passer dans certaines
hypothèses avant cette échéance et je
rappellerai comme d'ailleurs l'a tout à
fait souligné Madame Royale récemment je
rappellerai que tout ceci dépend de l'
viis que l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
aura à donner tranche par tranche sur
chacun des sites quant à la possibilité
sur chacun de ces sites de poursuivre la
l'exploitation pendant 10 ans de plus
voire 20 ans de plus voire davantage
puisque j'ai j'ai plaisir à vous dire
que aux États-Unis notamment des
installations nucléaires de la même
génération technologique sont en train
de dépasser les 60 ans et pour certaines
vont obtenir probablement des
autorisations d'exploitation jusqu'à 80
ans donc c'est quelque chose qu'il ne
faut pas non plus exclure sur le
territoire français et sur le parc sur
le parc français donc je pense notamment
par rapport aux questions que que posait
monsieur Dubois que je vous ai apporté
les réponses que je suis en mesure de
vous apporter de vous apporter
aujourd'huiz pas faire pas les rép mais
j'attends aussi monsieur le sénateur
j'attends que la PPE soit un nucléaire
soit soit précisé le président Courteau
sera aux avantp puisque président du
Conseil supérieur de l'énergie il aura à
connaître le premiers les propositions
du gouvernement sera saisi le
premier voilà je voudrais je voudrais
parler aussi de du travail que nous fait
que nous faisons dans
la structure industrielle qui nous
accompagne il y avait plusieurs
questions les questions de Madame
estroszi oui Madame nous avons des
difficultés dans certains métiers et et
et je dois vous dire que quand je visite
certains chantiers que je regarde et
j'essaie de parler avec certains euh des
des opérateurs et que j'ai du mal à
communiquer dans ma langue avec eux
c'est quelque chose que je regrette
j'aimerais bien pouvoir communiquer dans
ma propre langue avec les opérateurs qui
soudent par exemple sur sur nos
chantiers et nous avons il faut le
reconnaître un déficit aujourd'hui dans
la capacité qu'a notre système éducatif
notamment dans enseignement
professionnel à répondre dans certains
métiers du nucléaire je ne suis pas sûr
que ça soit le cas des cadres et des
ingénieurs je pense qu'il s'agit
plutôt plutôt des des soudeurs des des
tuyaux hauteurs des robinettiers des
monteurs électriques enfin dans ces
métiersl nous avons nous avons des
difficultés donc nous y travaillons
étroitement nous y travaillons notamment
parce que nous préparons le grand
carénage avec toutes les ETI et toutes
les PME qui nous qui nous accompagnent
et nous essayons de le faire dans les
bass bassin d'emploi dans certains
bassins d'emploi où je me suis rendu il
y a des choses très très fortes qui se
qui se font mais c'est un souci en effet
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas adéquation
entre la demande dont nous sommes les
porteurs et et l'offre de compéten dans
certains de de nos métiers et je crois
que des évolutions sont nécessaires dans
la manière dont
sont
orienté nos jeunes concitoyens vers ces
métiers où il y a des besoins
les évolutions sont nécessaires pour que
davantage on puisse parler le français
sur nos
chantiers je
voudrais également sur la la stratégie
industrielle dire que nous travaillons
très étroitement avec les é et les PME
monsieur Leroi vous en aviez parlé et et
également monsieur bzino qui
s'inquiétait de notre notre stratégie
industriel nous
avons des concertations à la fois
nationales et locale avec les
entreprises qui nous
accompagnent on peut toujours faire
mieux mais je crois quand même que nous
avons mis en place tous les process
toutes les méthodes qui nous permettent
de préparer nos partenaires c'est notre
intérêt comme c'est le leur aux
différents chantiers aux différents
travaux qu'ils vont devoir faire faire
pour nous voilà et enfin sur le
nucléaire je voudrais dire un mot de
démantellement parce que Madame bataille
m'a posé des questions sur sur
CGO monsieur Labé également alors
d'abord soyons très très clair moi je
signe les comptes d'EDF et dans les
comptes deedf il y a des provisions pour
la gestion des déchets en fin de vie et
pour le démantelllement des
installations et si je signe les comptes
avec sérénité comme le soulignait
quelqu'un tout à l'heure c'est parce que
je me suis assuré que ces comptes sont
sincères parce que sinon je suis en
faute et je me suis assuré notamment par
exemple s'agissant de CGO s'agissant du
du démantelllement que nous avons mesuré
à leur juste valeur les dépenses qui
vont devoir être faites et nous le
faisons en fonction de notre expérience
puisque nous sommes déjà aujourd'hui en
train de démanteler certaines centrales
au graphite à Chinon à buget et cetera
de la génération précédente et que nous
avons par nous-même établi des devis et
que ces devis ont été vérifiés par nos
commissaires au compte mais que
régulièrement la Cour des comptes se
penche sur ces provisions et que encore
tout récemment le ministère de
l'environnement de l'énergie et de la
mer a fait procéder à un 3è audit
indépendant par des des des experts et
que j'ai sur mon bureau le rapport des
experts commandés par le ministère le
rapport de la Cour des comptes et le
rapport de mes commissaires au comptes
qui me disent oui monsieur le Président
vous pouvez signer ses comptes parce
qu'il reflète sincèrement les dépenses
qu'il va falloir ir faire pour démeler
le parc et je voudrais aussi souligner
que ces activités sont pour nous projet
industriel important que j'ai d'ailleurs
réorganisé à mon arrivée en confiant à
une personne unique le soin d'assurer la
gestion globale de nos compétences de
nos projets d'optimiser nos dépenses et
que nous nous sommes nous-même un
opérateur sur certains domaines et nous
avons une filiale qui s'appelle socod
qui est principalement basée sur la
région ronalpe et qui est même traite un
certain nombre de ces matériaux qu'il
faut démanteler et et gérer dans la
durée et sur 6 Goo vous aurez remarqué
que suite à l'arrêté du ministère qui a
augmenté la dépense prévisionnel sur 6Go
pendant les 130 ou 150 ans qui viennent
nous avons augmenté nous-même la
provision dans nos comptes sur CGO nous
l'avons augmenté de 800 millions vous
avz de 800 millions d'euros dans les
comptes que que j'ai signé que Monsieur
GIR également a signé au titre de
l'année 2015 donc s'il doit y avoir des
dépenses supplémentaires nous les
insrivions dans nous les inscrivons dans
nos comptes et croyez bien et croyez
bien que je serais très mal à l'aise si
je ne reflétais pas dans les comptes que
je signe la connaissance que j'ai des
dépenses futures et donc je ne le ferai
pas je reflète cela
dans dans nos
comptes
les il est pas supprimé il est baissé de
niveau c'est la qui finance ridicule et
qui n
pr allez
je donc
je et bien c'est une bonne transition
monsieur le sénateur pour parler
d'hydroélectricité alors je vous parle
je ne vous parlerai pas des passes à
poisson qui sont un sujet
important mais je dirais coûteux
également
en vous disant que c'est un sujet que
nous prenons très au sérieux car la
France a été mise en demeure de modifier
le régime qu'elle applique depuis une
quinzaine d'années et que la Commission
de Bruxelles la direction de la
concurrence de la Commission de
Bruxelles estime ne pas être conforme
aux directives que la France a elle-même
approuvé et et mise en place à la
travers des des lois successives et donc
nous avons en effet un souci c'est celui
d'assurer la continuité de la production
hydraulique et à travers la produ
hydraulique la continuité de ce que nous
faisons dans les territoires dans les
vallées parce que la ressource
hydraulique bien sûr a des effets
bénéfique sur l'irrigation et
l'agriculture sur la biodiversité sur le
tourisme et et et et bien sûr aussi sur
les ressources propres que nous payons
et je voudrais d'ailleurs rappeler que
Madame Lamur que nous payons les
redevances hydrauliqu qu'elles sont
prévu dans les textes là de la même
façon j'aurais du mal à à ne pas payer
ce qui est ce qui est prévu
euh alors la la la commission nous a
fait savoir il y a quelques temps
qu'elle
souhaitait discuter avec l'État français
et accessoirement avec EDF de la manière
dont cette mise en demeure va
être la réponse je dirais concrète et
pas simplement de la réponse juridique
il une réponse juridique qui a été
formulé par l'État et EDF a également
apporté sa propre contribution cette
réponse juridique mais je crois que ce
qui est important c'est de voir comment
on sort de tout cela et donc il est un
peu tôt pour en parler puisque le
message que nous avons de la commission
est récent mais ce message c'est un
message mais asseyons-nous autour d'une
table et discutons de la manière dont
les choses vont évoluer des appels
d'offre seront sûrement lancé à un
certain moment bien évidemment
EDF y répondra c'est une évidence nous
souhaitons conserver notre patrimoine je
crois que nous faisons un bon travail en
matière d'exploitation du système
hydraulique hydraulique français et nous
avons d'ailleurs en tête que le
potentiel hydraulique français pourrait
être dans certaines conditions encore
amélioré avec certaines infrastructures
qui n'ont pas été construites ces
dernières années qui pourrai l'être si
les conditions étaient étai
réunies voilà je pense avoir à peu près
répondu sur sur l'hydraulique je
voudrais dire un mot de RTE notamment
madame bataille a parlé de
de RTE
euh monsieur gréiller aussi que comment
voyons-nous RTE
euh il y a aujourd'hui une situation qui
est un peu curieuse pour quelqu'un qui
comme moi vient de l'extérieur et qui
s'aperçoit que RTE est détenu à 100 %
par EDF mais que compte tenu du rôle
essentiel de RTE pour assurer un
répartition juste
des des connexions des moyens de
production au au résseau de
transport dans sa grande sagesse et on
peut comprendre pourquoi le régulateur
impose à EDF de ne pas se mêler des
affaires de RTE d'ailleurs je répondrai
cétait l'une des l'une des dernières
questions monsieur CALV que je ne suis
pas capable de vous parler du
fonctionnement de la ligne avec
l'Espagne car c'est RTE qui s'en occupe
et que je n'ai même pas le droit de
poser la question en pratique mais vous
vous avez de poser la question à
Monsieur Brot lorsque vous le
verrez et donc et donc le le
l'étanchéité de de dans la gestion dans
le fonctionnement dans le management
entre RTE et dEDF est total et néanmoins
nous détenons 100 % du capital de RTE et
donc nous avons un projet qui s'inscrit
dans la loi actuelle donc qui ne prévoit
pas de changer les disposition
législative qui impose que la totalité
du capital du RTE soit détenu par des
structures du
du public des structures publiques donc
à l'intérieur de ce cadre où tous les
tous les actionnaires de RTS sont
publics nous avons le projet d'ouvrir le
capital dès lors que cela s'inscrit dans
le projet d'entreprise dans la stratégie
que François Brot et ses équipes sont en
train de de de préparer et ce projet le
gouvernement a demandé à à François Brot
et à moi-même de le préparer au
printemps et de le mettre en place cette
année j'espère que ça pourra être fait
car ça pourrait je crois donner une
ouverture stratégique importante à RTE
mais c'est à François Brod de le dire et
ça pourrait aussi donner à EDF une
vision quand même plus logique de son
patrimoine puisque détenir un actif à
100 % mais ne pas pouvoir le gérer c'est
quand même un petit peu bizarre si vous
me permettez si vous me
permettez nous ferons dire François
Brotte président du
RTE voilà vous aviez des questions sur
les effectifs oui oui alors je voudrais
vous dire que les effectifs de DF ont
beaucoup augmenté ces dernières années
de bien plus que 3000 ou 4000 emplois
plutôt de l'ordre de 10000 et donc là
maintenant nous allons les faire baisser
un peu par rapport à une augmentation
forte qui a eu lieu ces dernières années
et pourquoi cette augmentation forte et
bien parce que nous avions beaucoup
embauché lorsque le programme
électronucléaire a été lancé ça pe-être
du temps du du président Pompidou ou du
des début de la du président
giscardestin et et nous avions beaucoup
pembauché et donc nous devons nous
préoccuper de remplacer les compétences
et notamment dans certains métiers du
nucléaire on ne devient pas expert
compétent pour gérer des sujets qui sont
difficiles simplement avec quelques mois
de de formation il faut plutôt parler
d'années entre la formation un peu
théorique et puis la formation sur le
terrain et nous avons organisé ce ce un
dispositif dans lequel nous avons
beaucoup embauché au début de la
décennie comme je le disais tout à
l'heure nous avons formé les personnes
que nous avons embauché nous les avons
mis en binôme avec les anciens un
mentoring comme on dit aujourd'hui et
puis maintenant les anciens partent à la
retraite et les nouveaux sont déjà là
parce qu'ils ont été embauchés il y a
quelques années et que nous allons ainsi
pouvoir opérer exploiter le réseau en
toute sûreté avec une très bonne
performance industrielle et en ne
remplaçant pas en effet la totalité des
départs en retraite mais ce que nous
prévoyons je voudrais souligner c'est
que nous allons au total si on prend
cette espèce de bosse suivi d'une
réduction nous allons avoir au total
plus d'emplois chez EDF on peut
s'interroger là-dessus que nous n'en
avions au début de la décennie alors
même que la consommation n'augmente pas
ce qui évidemment est quelque chose qui
nous nous nous interpelle mais à ce
stade nous prévoyons donc ces
diminutions qui sont tout à fait sous
contrôle évidemment il continuera à y
avoir des embauches et notamment faire
en sorte que le réseau dans sa
capillarité loc continue à à bien
fonctionner nous continuerons aussi à
embaucher en matière de recherche et
développement et Monsieur bzino
s'inquiétait de de de de ce sujet donc
nous continuerons à à embaucher de façon
à mener la totalité des missions qui qui
sont les nôtres néanmoins il y aura
certaines certaines réductions
d'effectifs et en ce qui concerne les
économies madame bataille notamment
avait abordé ce ce sujet et bien nous
allons travailler sur le cadre du plan
général qui a été présenté en conseil
d'administration nous allons travailler
à mettre en place les économies qui
correspondent à cette nouvelle
trajectoire je voudrais répondre sur le
sujet
de des actifs thermiques et notamment
madame prima nous avons un projet à
Porcheville qui est aujourd'hui en
consultation nous avons sur sur
Porcheville
ouvert un dialogue social avec les
instances représentative du personnel
pour préparer une éventuelle mise à
l'arrêt de Porcheville un peu plus tôt
que prévu nous le prévoyons précédemment
début des années 2020 nous envisageons
de le faire en 2018 et pourquoi cela et
bien parce que même dans les cas
aujourd'hui que je citais de de risque
sur le réseau il n'y a pas aujourd'hui
de rentabilité mais il n'y a même pas
non plus de fonctionnement les ces
installations d'ailleurs je souligne que
deux des quatre tranches ont déjà été
fermé en
2008 deux des quatre tranches ont été
fermé dans 2008 il reste deux tranches
il reste environ 190 salariés quelques
dizaines de prestataires et donc nous
projetons nous projetons cette fermeture
nous en discutons avec les autorités
politiques locales également j'ai
rencontré Monsieur Bédier qui est le
président du conseil général des
ivelines et nous essayons de voir avec
lui comment optimiser la gestion du site
avec une partie du site qui est destinée
à rester chez EDF mais une partie du
site sur laquel nous envisageons avec le
Conseil Général donc de mettre à
disposition ou de céder du terrain pour
revitaliser ce site qui a une vocation
industrielle m'a dit Monsieur Bédier
mais c'est à luiorganiser
son ces chosesl donc je suis très
attentif au au cas de de porscheville et
bien évidemment pour les
effectifs concernés pour les
prestataires concernés nous ferons bien
les choses puisque nous avons des
cellules de reclassement qui se mettront
en place le moment venu
puisqueaujourd'hui la décision n'est pas
formellement prise elle est encore dans
le cadre de
la de la
consultation je vrais parler un petit
peu de recherche et développement pour
vous dire que nous essayons avec les
moyens qui sont les nôtres vous aviez
des questions vous étiez assez nombreux
à avoir des des questions là-dessus
monsieur bourkin notamment
euh l'hydrogène voilà Monsieur R d'une
certaine façon à travers les objets
connectés nous essayons de répartir nos
dépenses de recherche et développement
je rappelle qu'elles sont de 600
millions d'euros par an nous essayons de
les répartir en fonction de nos
différents objectifs stratégiques faire
que dans une entreprise la recherche et
développement soit cohérente avec la
stratégie la stratégie cap 2030 don dont
je parlais donc nous avons bien
évidemment une partie importante de
notre recherche et développement dans le
domaine de la production classique si je
puis dire le
nucléaire la
production de d'énergie renouvelable
l'hydraulique que nous sur lequel nous
nous travaillons aussi pour certaines
optimisations notamment sur le centre de
Chatou mais nous essayons aussi
d'anticiper ce que va être le marché de
l'énergie dans les années qui viennent
donc nous avons de nombreux travaux en
matière de recherche et développement
autour des réseaux
intelligents autour de l'utilisation du
numérique pour optimiser
l'efficacité d'efficacité de notre
production et au niveau de l'utilisation
des technologies numériques pour
optimiser la manière dont nos clients
dans les territoires vont eux-mêmes
optimiser leur consommation organiser
les moyens de production locaux nous
avons un un un très gros chantier qui
est mené sous l'égie de de RDF en
matière de Smart Grid parce que la
gestion d'un réseau si je peux dire dire
centralisé c'est entre guillemets simple
c'est évidemment très compliqué mais
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué d'avoir un
réseau dans lequel en fonction de de de
caractéristiques qui peuvent aller et
venir très vite comme le vent et le
soleil vous devez
injecter localement de très très très
nombreuses installations qui viennent se
substituer au courant qui venait qui
vient de de du du réseau centralisé donc
le les smart grid sont des des sujets
très importants nous avons des expéri
expimentation j'en ai j'en ai visité
trois dans trois trois grandes villes en
France à Lyon à Nice et à Toulouse et
nous essayons de faire en sorte que que
nous soyons au premier plan parce que
c'est un sujet tout à fait majeur c'est
un sujet qui intéresse les territoires
qui intéresse les métropoles mais aussi
les territoires en général et et donc
nous essayons d'être d'être présents
là-dessus et
d'insérer petit à petit le compteur
Linky dans un écosystème qui lui
permettra de rendre tous les services
qu'on peut attendre du compteur linquier
je voudrais dire un mot là-dessus
d'abord le compteur Linky ne rendra ses
services qu'à ceux des clients de DF ou
des concurrents DF qui le souhaite ce
sont des systèmes où il faut être
volontaire pour s'insérer dans un
écosystème d'optimisation de la
consommation les informations du
compteur Linky elles ne sont disponibles
que pour que aerdf pour faire la
facturation et ce ne sont que les
Français qui décideront qu' qu'ils
veulent participer à un système
d'optimisation de leur consommation
d'électricité qui pour pourront donner
le droit à leurs prestataires d'accéder
à des informations de Linky mais les
Français qui ne le souhaitent pas et
bien le le la seule information de Linky
ce sera l'information de comptage qui
permet la facturation à à à à DF et je
voudrais souligner parce qu'on parle
d'électrosensibilité que d'abord nous
avons en effet quelques quelques soucis
avec des communes de ça et là qui n'ont
pas l'air enthousiaste à l'idée qu'il y
a un compteur numérique et qui délibère
dans ce sens et que nous essayons de
leur faire comprendre par différents
moyens que la loi doit s'imposer partout
et puis nous avons aussi quelques
quelques personnes qui s'inquiètent d'un
d'un compteur
et moi je voudrais simplement rappeler
que les
émission d'onde radioélectrique par par
le compteur Linky sont extrêmement
modestes euh elles sont très très
inférieures par exemple à ce que sont
les émissions d'objets ménager tels que
les fours à micro-ondes par exemple qui
émettent beaucoup ou même la plupart des
des des objets que nous que nous
utilisons donc je crois qu'il faut
essayer d'être raisonnable sur sur ces
sujet là voilà je vais terminer
peut-être si vous me le permettez
j'espère avoir à peu près oui je rassure
sur les questions
financières sur les questions
financières le prix du baril la loi et
tout ça alors le prix du baril c'est le
d'abord il est un peu remonté il est
plus autour de 45 dollars aujourd'hui
que que de 30 bon le prix du charbon lui
n'a pas vraiment remonté donc il faut
regarder la corrélation entre les
différentes énergies le le le prix du
baril a un peu remonté le prix du
charbon n'a pas remonté parce qu'il y a
le phénomène du gaz de schiste aux
États-Unis qui fait qu'il y a trop plein
de charbon aux États-Unis qui se déverse
en Europe et que ceci a a abaissé les
prix de l'électricité de façon
considérable alors à ces prixl bien sûr
euh laaren et la loi Nome ne s'appliqu
pas on est tous d'accord là-dessus hein
euh nous avons l'obligation de vendre à
42 € du mgawh une partie de notre
production nucléaire mais quelqu'un qui
peut l'acheter à 28 € du mgawh on voit
pas pourquoi il aurait l'acheter à 42
donc depuis maintenant de semestres nous
ne vendons plus du tout du tout
d'électricité à au prix au prix de
laaren ce qui d'ailleurs amène à
s'interroger sur cette partie-là de la
loi Nome et et ce système dans lequel
quand les prix sont élevés c'est au
dériment de DF et quand les prix sont
bas c'est au détriment deedf c'est pas
un très bon système on aimerait trouver
mieux je suis d'accord avec vous
monsieur le monsieur le le sénateur
c'est pas c'est pas ce qu'il y a de
mieux voilà alors au total nous avons
donc cette situation financière dont je
parlais je répondrai au sénateur
ponatovski que nous avons optimisé le
les investissements du grand carénage
d'environ 15 % et qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui de 51 milliards d'euros
courants alors qu'ils étaient
préalablebl de 55 milliards d'euros en
EURO 2012 nous sommes passés des euros
2012 aux euros courant de 55 à 51 et
donc c'est c'est voilà c'est sur la
période
2014-2025 je répondrai aussi au sénateur
patovski que nous avons l'intention sur
Areva de dépenser non pas de milliards
et demi d'euros mais la moitié de cette
somme puisque nous avons l'intention
d'acheter 51 % d'Areva et non pas 100 %
Areva lui d'Areva NP pardon Areva
lui-même va garder une partie d'Areva NP
et nous aurons
j'espère des partenaires nous discutons
avec eux des partenaires asiatiques qui
prendront une partie du capital dans le
cadre de partenariat stratégique que
nous avons avec
ces ces partenaires asiatiques d'un côté
nos amis chinois et de l'autre côté nos
amis nos amis japonais et puis notre
dette vous l'avez souligné elle a
augmenté chaque année la dette comptable
est aujourd'hui de 37 milliards d'euros
c'est un chiffre qui est élevé il y a
des engagements hors bilan qui euh
rendent les agences de notation
euh dans
une situation d'examen détaillé de notre
capacité à rembourser cette dette euh
parce que nous avons des engagements qui
sont horban notamment en matière de
retraite et que nous avons donc des des
perspectives qui méritent une grande
attention il faut que nous puissions en
toute circonstances lever la dette sur
les marchés dont nous avons besoin pour
renouveler cette dette sur les trois
prochaines années pas de pas de de
de difficulté particulière puisque nous
avons assez peu de remboursement de
dettes à renouveler par contre à
l'horizon 2020 nous avons beaucoup de
dettes à à renouveler et notamment une
dette hybride qui a été construite en
2013 et et 2014 et qui nécessite qu'on
regarde les choses avec beaucoup de de
précaution et donc l'évolution de la
dette je crois que je l'avais dit
d'ailleurs lors de mon arrivée est
vraiment un sujet de préoccupation et et
de ce point de vue
là
l'impact d'une recapitalisation d'EDF à
travers les mesures prises sur le
dividende et la l'augmentation de
capital que nous préparons pour la fin
de cette année il est réel il est
significatif c'est un impact qui est
significatif et les choses ont été
calculées par nous de manière à rendre
nos investissements et notre bilan
cohérent nous aurons après cette
augmentation de capital les moyens de
financer nos investissements et les
moyens de faire le grand carénage je
réponds aussi au au sénateur patovski
par nous-même nous n'avons pas
l'intention aujourd'hui d'ouvrir le
capital de nos centrales nucléaires il y
a quelques centrales mais c'est très
mineur dont les euh euh des
participations très minoritaires à chaud
à buget je crois
fenheim show budget Fessenheim il y a
quelques participations et aussitin et
Tricastin
euh mais aujourd'hui nous détenons
quasiment 100 % de ce parc et nous nous
notre intention est de continuer à
détenir 100 % de ce parc sur les
sessions d'actifs je répondrai à
Monsieur monsieur
Vincent
nous
ilô je dirais qu'en effet nous prévoyons
de vendre 10 milliards d'euros d'actif
mais que nous n'avons pas de répartition
détaillée année par année mais sur ces
10 milliards d'euros si nous nous en
arrivions à vendre 6 milliards dès cette
année trou ça formidable je pense pas
qu'on y arrivera je pense qu'il faut
mieux imaginer que sur les années 2016-
2017 quelque chose d'un peu écou réparti
et et quelque chose d'un peu lissé non
pas que évidemment si nous arrivons à
bien vendre très vite les actifs que
nous voulons vendre on aura fait un très
bon travail mais nous sommes plus
prudents que cela dans nos prévisions de
de
trajectoire de trajectoire financière
voilà je crois que j'en ai à peu près
terminé sur la quasi totalité des des
sujets vous m'aviez parlé de l'incidence
de la baisse du cours de bourse sur
l'entreprise et bien je dirais qu'elle
est indirecte elle est indirecte
puisqueaujourd'hui l'entreprise constate
que le cours de bourse a baissé que les
investisseurs qui étaient rentrés au
moment de la mise en Bourse ou qui ont
acheté des titres sur le marché on ont
perdu de l'argent ce qui est
parfaitement regrettable et je pense
notamment au fait que certains salariés
eux-mêmes ont souscrit et n'ont pas fait
une bonne affaire mais aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas d'effet direct sur
l'entreprise c'est plutôt notre
réputation notre image ou l'image que
peut avoir l'entreprise lorsqu'elle lève
de la dette alors nous avons levé de la
dette sans difficulté en octobre 2015
nous avons une très bonne couverture par
les marchés de dette de l'évolution des
choses donc nous n'avons pas de tension
aujourd'hui sur ce qu'on appelle le CDS
c'est-à-dire la prime de risque qui est
mise sur la dette deedf je m'excuse
c'est un peu technique donc notre dette
se tient bien comme l'on dit mais nous
sommes extrêmement vigilant parce
qu'entre le cours de bourse et la
croissance régulière de l'endettement
deedf nous ne pouvons pas laisser les
choses dériver et c'est pour cela que
nous avons préparé
présenté au conseil d'administration le
plan que je vous ai décrit aujourd'hui
voilà j'ai à peu près terminé je vous
remercie monsieur sur en ce qui concerne
la Dominique j'ai compris que cette
cette installation le l'appel d'offre
avait été remporté par un concurrent et
ce sont des choses qui arrivent et et
euh
pardon c'est pas très favorable ah c'est
possible
mais vous savez nous nous nous ne nous
n'avons vocation à répondre à beaucoup
d'appels d'offre mais il faut aussi euh
de temps en temps accepter de ne pas
tous les gagner monsieur le Président au
moment où tout le monde se lait je
voudrais vraiment vous remercier pour la
précision des réponses que vous avez
apporté il y a eu beaucoup de questions
vous l'avez vu tout le monde a été
extrêmement respectueux du temps de
parole vous vous-même en un temps
finalement relativement court avait
apporté je crois beaucoup beaucoup de
réponse écoutez merci encore d'être venu
ici et nous poursuivrons nos échanges
avec en effet François
Brot qui sera invité à venir devant nous
la séance est levée
merci voilà pour l'audition de jeanbert
Bernard Lévi le PDG de DF qui s'est
exprimé la semaine dernière pendant près
de 2 heur devant les sénateurs de la
commission des affaires économiques
Jean-Bernard Lévi pour qui le projet
d'inkle point en Grande-Bretagne reste
un projet stratégique et qu'il faut
mettre en place dès que possible
Jean-Bernard LVI a également confirmé la
fermeture prochaine de la centrale de
fenheim vous pouvez toujours voir et
revoir toutes les auditions sur notre
site
publicsenat.fr très bonne journée sur la
chaînes
parlementairirees